Okay, I'm good now.
Okay.
Hello, everybody.
Hello.
Sorry.
I'm okay for real now.
Okay.
I'm back.
For real.
I'm back for real.
I'm on my actual setup and everything.
So, like, everything is A-okay.
Not to Deadpool.
Thank you for the one.
Give the chip.
Thank you.
Mac, thank you for the five.
Give the chips.
Thank you.
All right.
Yes, I am back home.
As you can see, I sound a lot better.
I'm not, like, in a giant fucking echoey room this time.
Yeah, not... not... yeah.
It might still be a little scuffed, but, like, it's an improvement, you know?
Just... just... just a little bit of an improvement, which I will... I will take.
Um... um...
Um... so, yeah.
Sorry for being a little late.
I... I... I thought I timed it very perfectly, because it said I would arrive a lot earlier, and then I would be able to get home a lot earlier, and then my flight got delayed, and then it took fucking forever to, like, get off the goddamn plane, and then... okay,
it took forever for it to fly, and then it took forever for the plane to, like, fly... like, get off the plane, because people were, like, taking fucking forever, because I was at the very back, and then, um...
Because, okay, this is more so like a little bit of paranoia as someone that takes a lot of flights for once.
I actually did economy because... I did economy because I was like, okay, you know what?
I need to start to save.
I need to save.
I shouldn't be, like, spending so much money.
I was like, all right, I should... with the concert being a lot of money, maybe I should, like, fly economy this time.
And so I decided to do economy, but I chose the seat at the very back because, um, statistically, uh... Okay, this is more like... this is a bit of, like, a little, like, doomer fact for you guys.
A little like, oh, now you're gonna be paranoid.
Now it's gonna be, like, a fucking underlying fear for you.
But if it's an underlying fear for me, I'm here to spread the fear to everyone.
But, like, statistically, more people survive if you're at the back of the plane.
So... So... So... So I was just like, all right, I'm gonna be at the very back.
If I'm gonna be in economy, I'll... I'll sit at the back.
Because statistically, I have more chance to survive.
I... So... Um... Um... Um... Uh... So, yeah.
So I was just, like, just, you know, I was just upping my statistics.
I was just trying to up my statistics.
I saw a lot.
I... I won't.
But... Um... Gus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I feel like I still hear a voice.
Next thing.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um... Anyway.
So... Uh... So, yeah.
So...
For some reason, the plane took fucking forever for it to unload.
And also took forever for...
Like... Um... To, like, leave the airport and everything.
So that's why I'm a little late.
I literally got home.
Use the bathroom.
Got home.
Turn on the PC.
Use the bathroom.
And then, like, got out back on the PC to set everything up.
Uh... Um... Uh... But, yeah.
So... I'm here now.
Uh... I sat next to a child.
Oh, God.
It's so hot.
Fuck.
Okay.
It's like it's... Oh, my God.
It's like it's, like, the summer or something.
Um... Anyway.
Um... I sat next to a child.
And, like... Okay.
So I always thought it was, like, a fucking meme.
You know?
Like... Okay.
So, like, you know how, like, children... You need, like, four different... Like, you have to have four different things playing at the same time on the screen to hold their attention?
So, like...
I thought that was a meme.
You know?
I thought that was just, like, an over-exaggeration.
But this child next to me... She had an iPad.
She was an iPad child.
And then her iPad... She was playing a game.
And then on the far... Like, the top right corner Was a fucking music video playing.
While she was... While she was playing her game.
And I was just like, why?
And, like, she was... She was doing, like, geometry dash While, like, a fucking music video was playing On the top right corner.
And then she was moving the music... The music video around Because she, like, needed a better view on stuff, too.
So she's like, oh, I'm moving on the top left.
And, like, you know, I just saw that.
I was like, oh my god, this is real.
Like, this...
That's real.
And then she was, like, not... She wasn't just playing Geometry Dash.
She was playing, like, other games.
I don't know what... I don't know.
It was... They were some weird-ass fucking games.
They were, like, obviously games for kids.
Anyway, so...
Um, so, okay.
What I thought was really funny was that... So, like, the dad was... The kid was like, can I sit on the aisle seat?
And then the dad was like, look, daddy needs his aisle seat.
It's the one thing I look forward to.
So depressing.
It was like, never have kids again.
I was just like, what the fuck?
Daddy needs his aisle seat.
Oh my god.
Oh, this is at the end of this.
I was like, bro, that's just...
That's too real.
That's actually too fucking real.
Don't take away the one thing I have left.
No, he has a...
No, the thing is...
Um, they have two kids.
Because the other kid is sitting with the mom.
Um, is sitting with the mom on the other side.
Because they're like, where do you want to...
Like, they're asking, which side do you want to sit?
And then, obviously, the iPad kid was like, I want to sit on the right side.
And not...
So, um...
So, yeah.
I was just like, Jesus fucking Christ.
Daddy needs his aisle seat.
Like, Jesus.
Like, do you really?
Do you?
Like, it's the little things in life that brings him joy.
And it's the fucking aisle seat at an airplane.
Um...
Yeah, bro.
I cannot overhear it.
Like, they were literally right next to me.
Like, I had to listen to it.
Um...
Sharko.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I just sleep whenever I go on a plane.
If it crashes, I die in my sleep.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
CB.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Statistically, flying is the safest way of transportation.
For pedestrians.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Unless you're on a helicopter.
Um...
I heard, like, helicopter.
You have...
There's a higher percentage for...
You know, you can Uber helicopters?
That's fucking scary.
Like, there's...
Like, Uber allows you to, like...
Allows you to order helicopters For like, in like, I guess like in like populated city, like in like bigger, richer cities, I saw like on short someone was like, oh my god, there's an option to use a helicopter?
Like, I'm like, why?
Like, why would you ever?
Like, I don't know, I guess it's faster?
But then, I don't know, the fear of that shit is actually fucking crazy.
Like, sometimes it is cheaper.
Yeah, I'm just like, and it's sometimes, Jesus Christ, I don't know.
I was like, the fear of that.
Anyway, um, all right, let me recount.
Now that I have my actual setup, I'll talk about some stuff I talked about on the Twitch streams for those who weren't watching the Twitch streams.
Um, um, I, um, I went to a modern witchcraft store while I was traveling because I was like, ooh, there was, they were like, there was like, I don't know.
Okay, they're like, how do you know it was a modern witchcraft store?
Like, you just know.
Like, the, like, the window display was like, was like, okay, the window display, from what I remembered, was, was like, there was like, drag, like, figures of like, giant, a giant figure of a fucking dragon.
And then there was like, like, like, not poison, like, like, um, what are they called?
Like, those little herbs wrapped together, like, it's a little mini broom, but like, there's no stick on it.
Um, oh, I don't remember what it's called.
And then like, there's that shit around.
And there's like, you know, like the herbs and mushrooms and stuff like that, around the window display.
So I was like, and then there's candles too.
And then they had like, some of these like, incense stuff.
And then I was like, you know what?
Yeah, sage.
Yeah.
Like, they had like, sage stuff on the, so I was like, oh, that's interesting.
So I like, went into like, the modern witchcraft store.
Because, you know, when will I ever see modern witchcraft?
I don't know.
When will I ever see a story that sells, like, modern witchcraft?
Like, I feel like that's just, like, out of nowhere.
Um, so I got really curious.
I was like, what the fuck?
Like, I was just like, what do they sell?
Like, so, you know, I talked about it on Twitch, but they have, like, you know, like, the capitalism, the capitalism of tarot cards, where, like, there was, like, basically a bunch of fucking tarot cards that were based off of various TV shows and games and series,
and then other, like, you know, more...
I guess they have, like, other tarot cards that are, like, more so, like, more based on their own IP and stuff like that, but there were still, like, two shelves just dedicated to tarot cards.
And I'm like, Jesus fucking Christ, do I really need a Game of Thrones tarot card?
Like, doesn't that, like, sort of eliminate the, uh, the use of... Imagine getting your fucking fortune read with a Game of Thrones tarot card.
I was just...
Yes, it's very, very witchy.
Um, anyway...
Anyway...
Um, there was that, and then there's, like, um, there's lots of fucking candles shaped like cats, and, uh, there was, like, um, and they had, like, a whole bookshelf of, like, modern witchcraft spells and, like, um, and, like, old spells.
Like, not just modern witchcraft spells, but, like, old spells.
I was so tempted to buy one.
I was like, man, this would be a funny, silly, uh, stream idea.
And then I looked at how much it cost, and I was like, not so funny anymore.
I was like, wait, I think I could just order this off of Amazon.
I'm pretty sure.
I was like, oh, man, I mean, like, I'm pretty sure I could just order this off of Amazon.
I was like, I don't need to buy this at a modern witchcraft store.
The thing is, I was just like, you know what, I'm gonna save my space on my suitcase.
If I actually want to do it, I'll just order it off of it.
Imagine buying, okay, let me see if I can actually find the book.
The book was, okay, um, modern witchcraft spells.
It was literally, oh, there you go, I found it.
It was actually the modern witchcraft spell book.
Your complete guide to crafting and casting spells.
Oh, yeah, there you go.
Oh, it was cheaper.
So, this was the book I found.
I was like, hmm.
I actually found the book.
So, here, I'll show you guys.
This was like, here, I'll just give you guys the title.
And then you can, let me save this image.
And then you guys can see.
Okay, here you go.
This was like, this was the title of it.
And this was literally the book.
And I, like, I was, I was just, I almost bought this book.
Because I was like, hmm.
I was just like, what if I, what if I use this on stream?
But yeah, and then I looked at how much it cost.
Look, it was like $22, like, Canadian.
Okay, it's $22 Canadian on Amazon.
But, like, I was just like, okay, if... This is... I was like, okay, I could clearly Amazon this.
I... I could clearly... I could clearly Amazon this book.
But that's why I didn't buy it.
Because I was like, I'm not gonna waste my suitcase space for this fucking book.
Yeah, or I could just buy something off of... You're right.
I could just buy something off of Etsy and support my local witches, you know?
You're so right.
Wait, let me see.
Etsy.
Witchcraft.
Wait, is it true?
Wait, what can I even get?
Oh, there you go.
Oh, my God.
Supreme fuck around and find a voodoo doll.
Not a toy.
Hex revenge, voodoo, talisman, black magic, witchcraft, popping bones.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Oh, my God.
How many did this person sell?
Okay, I need to know who owns this one.
Okay, Mystic...
No way.
That's so much.
Oh, my God.
This guy has...
This guy... Oh, this guy has...
Sold a lot of voodoo dolls.
Fuck around and find a limited edition candle magic spell.
Hoodoo ritual.
Seven day wicka hex curse.
Revenge.
Hate.
Nasty.
Someone bought this.
They fucking sold 2,000 plus items.
Oh, my God.
Okay, I'll link you guys to the store and you guys can, like...
You guys can look at it yourself.
Like, I saw the voodoo dolls and I was like...
Oh, my God.
You're right.
Support your local witches instead of buying a $20...
Instead of buying a $20 book off Amazon.
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Are you sure that people who survived Playing Catchers were in the back?
Or is...
People were in the back in a situation where there was someone that...
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Anton, thank you, thank you.
Doc, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thankyou.
Why buy a book to cast spells when you're at...
You already steal our hearts?
Every stream will be allowed.
Thank you, super chat!
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Uh, Doki, you should become a witch.
Oh my god.
I don't know.
Maybe I should be, like, the wholesaler for witch products.
Because clearly they're fucking making bank.
What is this?
Supreme, sacred, shaman, medicine, woman, ultimate, Native American protection, wealth, prosperity, business, work, success, love, voodoo doll.
For $650 and it's 50% off, guys.
Holy shit, guys.
If you buy it, it's 50... Oh my god, they originally were selling it for $1,300.
Holy fuck.
But guys, look, it's 50% off.
What a deal.
You can now have the supreme, sacred shaman for $650.
How many did they sold?
I mean, they sold a lot of... Oh my... Okay, they sold a lot of voodoo dolls.
Some of them are, like, sold out.
If I buy a tarot reading, can I request, like... Can I request, like, certain tarots?
Can I be, like, can you use a Game of Thrones tarot cards for me, please?
Like...
What... What a deal.
Is there... Oh, is there a review?
Let me see the review.
All right.
Amazing work.
Just what I was looking for.
My daughter was kidnapped and got her home now.
So, we are suing.
So, I bought candles to boost our case.
What the fuck are these?
What?
Okay.
What the fuck?
Okay, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Why is it always on Super Mario, man?
Why is it when I'm, like, on the multi-part series where I have the most interesting topics that I want to talk about?
It's always these fucking streams where I go, like, wild.
Look at this.
Holy fuck.
All right.
Look at this.
Amazing work.
Just what I was looking for.
My daughter was kidnapped and got home now.
So, we are suing.
So, I bought candles to boost our case.
Like, these reviews are...
These reviews are actually all over the place.
Oh, my.
I did not expect that.
Why is this?
Okay.
Item arrived faster than expected.
Lovely and great burn.
Repeat customer here.
And then, you know what they bought?
Okay.
Look at...
I like this review.
Because you can see what they bought.
And you're, like...
They smell...
They sound like a normal review.
Until you read what exactly the item is.
Excellent candles.
Smell lovely and burn great.
Repeat customer here.
Three candle ritual set kit.
Fuck around and find out.
Doom revenge.
Return to sender.
Voodoo hoodoo.
Black magic.
Dark art.
War death.
And then, like...
Great candles.
They smell lovely.
I'm definitely gonna buy my song again soon.
Sharko, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
VTuber tarot cards.
When...
Medi.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The witch industry is insane.
Holy shit!
Oh my...
Um...
I like this review.
From...
Um...
I like this review.
This review.
Fabulous!
Beautiful!
Great quality!
Voodoo doll!
Custom spell!
Not a toy!
Powerful poppin doll!
Not hoodoo wicca!
That's...
Terrifying!
That's the goddamn ash baby!
But hey...
Fabulous!
Beautiful!
And great quality!
Five stars!
Guys...
Clearly...
Am I in the wrong business?
I'm kidding...
Do I...
Go into the cap...
The capitalism of witch magic?
Um...
So people can support local witches right now on Etsy?
So...
No!
These are not the things I bought!
I...
I was not...
I was just...
There were some things that were similar here...
But definitely I did not see the...
The...
The modern witchcraft store did not have an ash baby, unfortunately.
If there was an ash baby, I definitely would have bought one, I guess.
Maybe I would have bought the ash baby doll if they sold it at the store.
Um...
Oh my god!
Uh...
But yeah, that was interesting.
I thought...
I don't know...
That was...
Um...
A pretty fucking...
Wild tangent I went through.
Um...
Anyway!
Uh...
But yeah, that's basically...
I mean, there's other stuff I wanna...
I might wanna talk about later on.
But...
Yeah, I watched the...
You know, we did the Summer Game Fest.
So many games I'm really looking forward to are...
Um...
Like I said...
Sonic Racing Game.
Because there's Miku Hatsune.
Steve.
Because I'm looking forward to Miku Hatsune.
And Steve.
The Muppet Boxing.
And, um...
And the new Resident Evil game.
Um...
Jaxby, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, well...
I'm obviously...
For...
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
I need to show you guys the meme.
Thank you for reminding me.
I bookmarked, like...
When I...
I realized...
I've been, like, using bookmarks now.
Whenever I talk about...
Uh...
Also...
I...
I just remembered.
I said I'm looking forward to Sonic Racing.
But, like...
Do you guys know it's $90 Canadian?
Like...
Just for Hatsune.
Bro.
It's actually $90.
For...
Just because Hatsune Miku is in it.
It's...
90 Canadian dollars.
For Sonic Racing.
I'm like...
Are you fucking kidding me?
Holy shit.
Oh...
I don't think I can...
I don't think I can afford...
I don't think...
No, I can't afford it.
But, like...
There's a possibility...
That I might not buy the game.
But, anyway...
I love all the memes about the...
The new Marvel fighting game.
Because...
Okay.
This one was pretty funny.
Uh...
I love all the memes for it.
Because...
Because you just see Capcon on the corner.
Yeah.
Yeah...
Are you sure?
Yes.
And then there's this one.
The one where, like...
They're, like, doing the Jarvis...
Jarvis!
Frame data!
Please!
And then this one, too.
This one's one...
These are two of my favorite memes...
That came from the new fighting game.
It's like...
They're, like, doing the...
Jarvis!
What do I do?
And then it's all, like, fighting game analysis.
Uh...
Anyway.
Alright.
Enough.
Enough tangenting around.
It's time...
Let's actually go play Super Mario, man.
Alright.
Let me boot up the game real quick, guys.
Um...
Mr. Broken Bond.
They give us a super chat.
Did you think you get a witch skin suit?
And...
A witch product?
Okay.
Clearly...
Clearly, I don't know.
It clearly seems like a very lucrative business.
Alright.
Mario, man.
Oh, wait.
I need to get my controller.
Alright.
Gonna sell some voodoo dolls shaped like dragoons.
And be like...
Is there a dragoon you wanna curse?
Make an ash...
Ash baby dragoon doll.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh my god.
There's two of you guys now.
There we go.
Alright.
Getting my controller.
Go for later.
Alright.
Let's go.
Back to where it all began.
Super Mario Man.
With my actual save file.
Where am I?
I actually forgot.
Where is this place?
Oh, wait.
I remember.
It's...
It's the city.
Oh, it's New Doink City.
Okay.
Oh, we get that road to good use.
Oh, yeah.
They gave me a new...
They gave me a new ride.
My big bro and I love coming to the Metro Kingdom when we have enough saved up.
Sometimes we get a little overwhelmed with all the lights and noises.
So, we always visit a park with his headphones to relax.
He really likes watching these Goombas play.
Oh, he's a little shy guy.
Okay.
Mary Pauline does so much for the city.
She manages battles, things, and races.
Ah.
I do...
What do I do to go on a date with her?
Ask her out.
I don't have anything to give her.
Wait, Mario.
Mario, you have a heart scare?
You do?
Yeah, please have it.
All right.
Let's let the short king woo Pauline, my ex-girlfriend.
Thank you, Mario.
That's crazy.
Like, asking the ex how to fucking be with, like, Pauline.
You won't regret this.
All right.
Goodbye.
Welcome.
Is this your first time in New Doink City?
That's a city hall.
There's usually something fun here.
All right.
This is a big...
Wait.
This city seems to be bigger than, um...
What was it?
What was that other...
The Wario's area?
What's that?
What's an old toad like myself doing at work in a laboratory?
I'll have you know.
Elvin and I go way back.
I'm here to help my old friend whenever he has a need to.
Professor E-Gag really puts us through the works.
At least the work is fulfilling though.
Oh, he lives here?
Oh, this is E-Gag's place.
I thought he'd, like, be at Toad City.
Honestly, I don't even know why they hired me to keep watching at this place.
That game developer back there could wipe the floor with everyone in the world.
Well, that team of theirs.
I wonder why they didn't compete in the Gap Challenge.
Me and that toad guard over there are old buddies despite appearances.
We protected some high-profile targets in our day.
Professor E-Gag hardly even needs it.
He's strong, I tell you.
Oh, wait.
He's a strong trainer?
I mean, to be fair.
Like, he can capture any Mon that he wants.
We here at Gag Science are researching the science of Cap Battles.
As a result, the professor has become quite the expert.
I want that blonde girl that works near him.
They're really scary to go up against.
Is he actually that strong?
Does he, like, max level up his mons?
Hmm.
Wait, is that Alpha Red?
Here, let's see the professor?
Or that quirky group of developers in the corner?
Oh, yeah, that's the dev team.
Being an intern for the professor sure is hard work.
Okay, I recognize the devs there.
Hit it, I'm Kobe.
Oh, skip a, skip a.
How much we battle?
How about we battle once you become...
Oh, this is like a bonus area.
Wait, what's this?
Bing, bing.
Mario.
Oh, I see you finally reached my alarm.
Wonderfully done.
Yes, yes.
Here, let me give you a little something as a reward for making it this far.
Yay!
Free stuff.
Oh my god, it's John Mario, man.
That training module contains a move, boss wipe.
It should help you immensely when filling out the rest of your tile decks.
Speaking of...
You've been doing that, haven't you?
It's a great reward for you.
You can fill it out completely.
Oh, we're definitely gonna do that.
Oh, yeah.
I heard that like with the new Switch too.
Um, it like...
It like revolutionized shiny hunting.
Because apparently it's like so fast to shiny hunt now.
What's that?
Sorry.
Can't talk right now.
But I'll be here when the phone rings.
I got an email that Tastare in on Prince needs my help to hide his gold.
Can you believe it?
Yeah, apparently it like...
The newest rec world record...
It like beat the old world record for shiny hunting by like 25 minutes or something.
Um, yeah, well...
We'll get a job and stuff eventually.
For now, we're just crashing on the couch.
Ain't bothering anyone or nothing, I guess.
Me and my sister are kind of just chilling right now.
You know?
Big city life is too tough for us.
I can never live outside of a city.
I think I'd like die.
You'll find me in the woods.
This is ridiculous.
The owner here wants to work so badly that my desk is on the first floor.
It doesn't even consider working conditions.
No, you don't understand.
If I get...
If I get internet speed below...
Below 500 for five...
Below 500?
I...
You don't understand.
That you can never go back.
Guys, I've had fiber for way too long.
I cannot go back to what it once was.
You cannot...
I've lived...
I live with fiber...
And everything convenient around me.
Of everything being like...
Five to ten minutes around me.
For too long.
I have a friend...
That lives...
In the middle of fucking nowhere.
And then like...
He was like...
Yeah...
Food sometimes take like...
30...
Like sometimes take like...
40 to 50 minutes to get here.
And I'm like...
What?
Oh, so you order from like...
Downtown or something, right?
And then he was like...
No, it's like the closest...
Like restaurant near me.
I'm like...
The closest?
Wait...
And I'm like...
What about fast food?
What about like McDonald's?
Oh yeah...
That's like a 25 minute drive away.
And I'm like...
What?
What do you mean?
A 25...
Oh my god...
Not too bad.
You see here...
You see...
I live in the city.
The closest McDonald's near me...
I don't know what the closest McDonald's near me...
But I feel like the closest McDonald's near me...
Would be like five minutes.
Like a five minute drive.
Not a 25 minute...
You want five minute drive or fast food isn't terrible?
You see...
You don't know.
You might not live in the city.
I live in the city.
That's pretty fucking bad.
That's...
That's really...
That's really fucking bad.
I have everything conveniently located around me.
I don't live in the suburbs.
But everything is like conveniently around me.
Um...
Oh...
I'm the owner of this here building.
Uh...
We use it as an office space mainly.
And I must say...
We're very profitable as of late.
I knew putting even more desks...
And cramping the employees closer together...
Would help build team synergy.
Why are you looking at me like that?
Alright.
Ugh...
I hate this job!
Why should I have to keep...
These poor employees in line?
I'm just even in a manager position.
All I do is keep watch.
The owner here has some interesting ideas about team synergy.
For one, he makes us all dress up the same.
I don't even need these glasses.
Oh yes.
When they all look the same.
So you don't have to have like actual...
Like...
You don't have to put...
Like humanize them.
If they all look the same.
Also, I haven't had McDonald's in fucking years though.
To be fair.
Um...
Or...
Hmm...
Actually, maybe a year ago?
The only time I ever want to have McDonald's...
Is their chicken nuggies.
If I ever have like a chicken nuggie craving.
Quickly!
Take this!
Oh nice.
I got a koi.
I also haven't had like...
Soda in a while.
Or like...
Soft...
Um...
Soft drinks.
I'm sick of it!
I don't want the responsibility!
Oh wait.
Isn't amulet calling means I get more money?
Okay.
What is it?
Doubles money.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Give.
What does dad have?
I don't remember why I keep dad.
Alright.
What do you have?
What are you holding?
Uh...
What does the shell belt do again?
Guys?
Oh.
What?
I wasn't snacking off.
I swear!
I can't take this anymore!
Don't do it!
Don't jump!
Oh my god!
He was going to the window!
Holy fuck!
Oh, he doesn't need that.
Money's more important.
Oh my god.
He cleared.
He was actually going towards the fucking...
That's crazy.
Don't tell Nintendo.
Oh man!
I really done it now!
There's a window right here!
Do a flip!
Oh...
Silly...
Depression's not real!
So boring!
If our boss was in the cap challenge...
His type would definitely be the boring type!
I don't know why everyone here is complaining so much!
I got hired easily and barely have to work!
Surely everyone has the same...
Fuck here!
PTSD right there!
Hey there!
On your break?
Better head upstairs ASAP!
Then, so you can make most of your time!
Don't let the boss see you on the way up!
Alright.
Oh wait!
Oh!
This is a secret exit!
Oh where?
Bro.
I mean, if that boss treats me right...
Surely everyone has the same experience!
Alright!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Money more important than elf?
Who are you?
The government?
Woo!
Finally!
A peaceful respite from what bladder...
From that bladdering boss of mine!
Oh yeah!
That reminded me!
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna do Hunger Games, the emotes...
After...
At the end of the stream!
So we're gonna say goodbye to two emotes!
For those who don't know...
The member goons...
We have two new emotes!
But like...
Don't worry!
These emotes will be moved...
Will still be available on Twitch!
Because I have a lot of...
Twitch gives you a lot of emote slots!
But on YouTube...
There's like a maximum...
A very small maximum amount!
And your member goons have voted out...
Two emotes off the island!
So...
So like...
Sorry...
My brain actually died there...
I'm so...
I actually like...
Short-circuited a little bit...
But yeah...
So...
Say goodbye to the...
Two em...
To whatever the two emotes are...
Before the end of the stream...
You see those two twins downstairs?
I hear they're related to the owner of some way!
Because of that...
They're allowed to stay here while they're in between jobs!
Meanwhile...
All salary workers gotta put up with them...
While going about a job!
Honestly...
I'm really starting to get sick of them!
Uh...
Anton...
Thank you for the super chat...
Thank you...
Uh...
Doki...
Can we have 7TV on Twitch chat?
Yeah, we can!
We just...
I just need someone else to handle it!
I could like delegate that!
I'm just lazy!
When it comes to adding new stuff!
Lord Crowe says they give a super chat!
Thank you!
She blasts the city's dragoons!
The owner of this building hired me to predict the future of his company!
Quite honestly...
It's not looking good!
But I didn't tell him that!
He doesn't deserve my services!
Alas!
And all that!
What's that mean?
All landlords are shrooms!
But you don't hear that from me!
Alright...
Let's head off!
Woo!
Alright, where do we go?
What was this?
Oh, these were the store in the market!
No more sandy desert!
Hello, concrete jungle!
Oh, can I get up there?
No, okay.
Must be a way to get up there!
There's an item just sitting there!
Just sitting there!
Like I could grab it!
I have friends tell me that I'm not gonna get my wings unless I take a leap of faith!
I told him, No, thank you!
I'd rather stay on the ground!
Okay, want to go to my secret spot?
Okay, Cookie Koopa!
Oh, it's...
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh shit!
No, that's how they got it!
Lord Bowser!
Please!
Save me!
We're not done!
Oh my god, there's a toad gang!
The toad biker gang!
Guys!
I found a blue shell!
Oh...
Oh yeah, the new Switch 2 and Mario Kart World came out.
You know what's funny?
They didn't fix the drift prop.
They...
They kept...
I...
I heard that...
I heard that the Switch 2 Joy-Cons are still drifting because they didn't fix anything.
And then like...
Um...
And then like one of my friends was complaining about it on Discord.
I was like, are you fucking stupid?
Of course they're not gonna fix it.
Nobody cares.
Like...
That has been a problem for years now.
And you know what people do?
They just buy new Joy-Cons.
Nobody will stop them.
Why fix the thing when they're earning more money to buying new Joy-Cons?
Alright, let's see.
The Koopa Troop owns this building.
And when I say the Troop owns it, we got more share here than Lord Bowser.
A lot of us minions got together in Main Street and decided to purchase this building with our purple coins.
Thankfully, we got in before that market crashed.
Oh my god, are our purple coins like Bitcoin?
Mario, you're just in time to join us for a party!
What?
You thought we'd kick you up?
Nah, we don't actually mind you all that much.
Nothing ever changes.
Letters don't know it, but we're actually a mess of debt.
Turns out purple coins weren't the most reliable method of purchasing this land.
And now the city is after us on fraud charges.
Whoops, I may or may not have caused a market crash.
We took an insurance policy on this building, but it turns out it doesn't end up being very valid when you work with purple coins.
Here, you can just have it.
You're doing us a favor.
Obtain the blunder policy?
Wait, what's that?
I got insurance now?
Oh.
Raises speed?
Is that what insurance does?
What the fuck?
It raises my speed.
With the power of insurance.
We got way too many boxes in this building.
I doubt anyone would realize if I just took some for myself.
A little toilet paper here or there.
How would they know?
There's so much toilet paper.
There's so much toilet paper here.
Hey, man!
What's up?
Me?
I'm just bobbing, I guess.
Wanna join me?
Sure.
Cool!
Make yourself comfortable.
Alright.
Sometimes, it's just nice to take a...
Oh, it's this song!
I'm taking the sights, y'all know!
Everyone around us is so busy.
Always in a rush, don't you think they should slow it down?
That's what I'm trying to do, at least.
Recently, I've been so overwhelmed by trying to finish an important project of mine.
It means everything to me, and I want to see it to fruition no matter what.
But in that pursuit, I burned myself out pretty bad.
That's when I decided to get up!
Got up, walked up my house, and came here.
Don't you have a family?
Did you leave your family?
And here I remain, just taking it all in!
Nice!
Imagine he has a family, he just walked out.
Sorry about that!
Rambling, I mean!
Thanks, though!
I appreciate it here!
Here!
I have this!
Ooh, a legacy cap!
What's that?
Never forget to change your time!
It's important!
Yeah, surely he'll go back, right?
Come on!
I won't keep you longer!
He's gonna go back, right?
To his family?
All right, that was a legacy.
Made in com- com- Oh!
Oh, is it like- Oh!
It's like the old Mario hat, right?
Can't tell!
Can't tell what it looks like!
Sorry!
Nanny Polly has restricted entrance to the sewers!
You're getting the official permit to enter here!
Oh, I see you!
What to do?
Oh, it's a picture!
Yeah!
Yay!
Picture time!
Uh, what's over here?
Hey, I'm walking here!
All right, mister!
Holy shit, this is a big area!
This is a huge fucking map!
Jesus Christ!
A lot of movies are set in New Thong City!
I won't get to be an extra one day!
This is the best day of my life!
You ever see a group of bananas take a toad off the street and brought daylight?
Stuff him in the sack?
Throw him into an army and no lives to raise?
I'm telling you!
Don't mess with the loan sharks!
Okay, you guys over-exaggerated loan sharks!
I...
If I knew how fucking weak they were, I would have...
I would not have bought...
I would not have spent all my money on...
On, like...
Legas...
On, like, caps.
The mini training me has been a fantastic minion!
I've been able to grow my workforce exponentially!
There is one teensy tiny problem!
My minions hate water!
And they refuse to go into the sewer to retrieve the parts I need for my master plan!
To steal!
I mean...
Oh, wait!
That's...
It's grown!
Go to that moon!
I need a long thingy thang, a short gizmo gadget, and a secret ingredient.
Simple!
Wait, where are you?
One of you is the guy I traded.
One of you is the guy I threw...
Not threw, sorry.
I gave away to Gru.
It's not like Scam City or Crypto Kingdom.
Oh, this street lamp is broken?
All right.
All right, let's talk to...
Wait, Luigi!
What the fuck are you doing with my ex-girlfriend?
Huh?
Bro!
That's the bro code said you can never go...
Go after the exes.
A lot of people move to New Thang City thinking they'll make it big.
Sooner or later, they realize there's no such thing as making it big.
Instead, replace and find your place.
Bro!
That's the bro code!
You never try and go after your bro's ex!
Whoa there, friend.
Be careful your plan on heading past this hallway.
The employees of this building are way into Cap Challenge and all its wacky gimmicks.
So be prepared for some unconventional battle.
Wait, what does he mean by that?
Lights, camera, action!
What does he mean by unconventional?
Oh my god, he sent his own people in.
Alright, Luigi's not a bro.
I can't believe he would do this to me.
I can't believe it.
Wait, what did he do?
Oh, using his focus stash.
I was like, how are you alive?
I was like, bro, he's sad on you.
How the fuck are you alive?
There's imprints and everything.
What would Daisy say?
Is it because of the elephant man?
Is it because...
Alright.
A life that also hurts the user.
No, you are not hurting yourself.
Is it because of him?
Is he just not into that?
Oh, battle!
Oh, that's cute.
That's cute.
My item!
Okay, not cute no more.
How dare you?
I was trying to capitalize this fight.
Alright.
Yay!
Okay.
Here!
Sure you want to fight me?
Avocatia is completely invincible to all damage.
Well, want to go?
Don't say I didn't warn you!
There's no way.
There's no way they have a mod that's invincible to all damage.
Dry bones?
Oh, it's shiny!
It's like a little blue.
That's right.
Wait, what?
Does that work every time?
What is that?
Oh, no.
That's a lie.
I was like, what the fuck did he do?
Okay, never mind.
I was like, what the fuck is Wonder Guard?
Yay!
Kofi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I keep getting recommended videos about shit happening to you, but never actually watch.
Tyrant, so time for a change!
You seem hella chill.
To be fair, this is one of my more chiller, um, chill play-throughs.
Some other, some other streams get pretty fucking wild, but I'm glad you've been enjoying my stream.
Thank you for watching, and thank you for the super chat.
Go ahead.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Jump scare.
Noki-noki.
Birdo is in here?
Oh my god, don't worry.
Don't worry, Dragoons.
I'm getting your girlfriend in.
I'm...
Like, sometimes hand stuff just isn't enough.
Sorry.
It was just right there, guys.
I'm sorry.
Like, literally, it was, like, right there.
Like...
The fact it was a hat.
Alright.
Let's see.
Attack that observes half the damage inflicted.
Fuck it.
Let's just get Bug Bite out.
Alright.
Get out Drain Punch.
Or get Drain Punch in here.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Actual Birdo.
Okay.
This time...
We aren't gonna get Catfish, guys.
This time we're gonna have a good time.
Yay!
Wait.
Oh, he got jealous.
The hand got jealous.
Oh, why is he still in my party?
Don't think I forgot.
Don't think I didn't forget.
I'll give you one more chance, little guy.
One more chance.
I thought I could get the win on anyone if I can't jump on them.
Alright.
Get over here.
Behold my secret techniques!
Alright.
What's your secret technique?
Nice day for catfishing, isn't it?
Ain't it?
Oh-ho!
Alright.
Star Bag.
Don't worry.
I know how to beat this.
My one move.
My one move that gets super chats.
That's it.
Goodbye, Star Bag.
Yeah!
What a shy guy.
Oh, look how tiny he is.
Time to sit on him.
This has honestly been the best move he's ever learned.
What's he gonna do?
Electrocute me?
Paralyze me?
Don't worry.
I have another 10k lying around.
Alright.
Yay!
Bye, secret technique.
Alright.
What do you have for me?
Magus passed all my employees?
Well done!
But I won't be such a pushover.
Alright.
Time to beat up the boss and take his company.
Oh shit, guys.
I don't know if I should sit on that.
Guys.
I don't think it's a good idea to sit on that, guys.
For the sake of that.
We will not do it.
The coward!
Oh shit!
No!
They forgot to yell him!
Alright, that's fine.
That's fine.
That's not it.
Alright.
We just need grass.
We have stick bug.
Alright, stick bug.
This is your time to shine.
Alright.
Wait.
I don't have...
Wait, where's my grass move?
Shit.
I can't.
Sorry, I forgot about movesets.
Alright.
I forgot.
Okay.
That's not...
That's a bug.
Alright.
Don't worry.
This is your time to shine.
Right here.
Alright.
This is it.
This is your one chance.
If you don't make it.
Okay.
Nevermind.
I guess he didn't make it, guys.
I...
I guess he...
He didn't make it.
Alright.
I mean, bugs live on grass.
That's like...
That's how it works, right?
You set him up for failure.
How did I...
Okay.
I thought that like...
You know...
He would...
The boomerang would have like a watered subtype.
Okay.
And I thought that, you know...
He'd be okay.
I thought...
I thought he would survive.
I didn't expect him to fucking get demolished by one move.
Hammer Bros said again.
Holy fuck.
Bro.
Okay.
Hammer Bros is a little too strong.
Hammer Bros might be a little too strong, guys.
A magnet bomb.
Yeah.
Surely that would do more damage, right?
Oh, yeah.
It does.
Nice.
Okay.
That's fine.
Heffley, you got this.
I believe in you.
Okay.
The boss might be a little strong.
It might be a mistake to let die...
To let dad die there.
Okay.
I have a secret weapon.
You are not sleeping.
You're not sleeping.
My secret weapon will not learn how to sleep.
If I'm not sleeping, you're not sleeping.
Okay.
Yeah, let's...
You know what?
I believe in you.
I'm a...
It's a fucking giant T-Rex.
There's no way.
All right.
It's time...
Ooh.
Breaking sweat.
All right.
It's time to use the dragon tail.
Yes!
Slam him!
Slam him again!
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Never mind.
He protected himself.
And then I have poison.
Okay.
That's a little awkward.
Slam him again!
Yes!
I knew...
I knew my T-Rex will win this.
Yay!
Everybody's leveling up.
Let's go!
Um...
My strategy!
What was it?
Crabble!
Not many people in New Donk City can feed all of us like that.
Here!
Go ahead and have this!
Wait, I did all of that and all I got was a fucking TM40.
Also, by the way, that reminded me...
I came back from traveling and then I saw that Bandai sent me something.
And I was like, oh, what's this?
And then it was like related to like...
Um...
The Elder Ring...
Night...
Night Ring thing I participated in.
And then it's literally a t-shirt where like...
I...
I played Elder Ring...
Night Ring...
And I defeat...
And all I got...
And I...
And I defeated...
Like I defeated the Night Lord and all I got was this t-shirt.
Type shirt.
So it was literally like...
The front was like...
Elder Ring...
Night Ring...
And the back was like...
I defeated a Night Lord.
So it's literally one of those shirts.
I...
And the back lady said, I defeated the Night Lord.
So it felt like I participated in the event and all I got was this t-shirt.
Come back and fight us again anytime.
Don't be a stranger.
Wow.
I know.
I'll show a photo of it later.
My participation award.
Yeah, yeah, like the fucking speedrunners got an actual, like, sword.
A sword?
What was that?
A shield?
And something else?
And all I got was a t-shirt.
I defeated the Night Lord and all I got was a t-shirt.
Yeah, the people who won the competition...
Because it was, like, a low-key tournament.
And, of course, like, you know, whoever kills the Night Lord the fastest...
The three Night Lords the fastest.
So, of course, like, the speedrunner...
Um, the speedrunners were gonna...
We're gonna win that.
And the prize was literally, like, a sword and a shield.
What's this?
Welcome to New Donk City Pit.
Are you willing to hit and reap the rewards of win?
What's this?
Once you explore, death's with pit and try to reach...
Oh, okay.
Oh, so...
Wait.
For a special explorers pack for your items.
You fill out any items once...
And there can be no rest until you make it.
Wait, can you catch them?
Sorry, I did skip a skip a...
Seven villains, but also wild captures.
Oh, you can capture things!
But can you actually keep them?
It doesn't say.
Oh, you're gonna keep one after...
Okay, goodbye.
If I can't keep, I leave.
One after seven rounds?
That's too much.
That's too many.
That's one too many rounds.
Alright, I'll watch.
Take...
Take that, Pauline!
Private, use razor shell!
I forgot the accent I gave Luigi.
Luigi is the victor!
Luigi!
Aw, you're all so kind.
And you'll make this so much fun.
Great idea to battle outside, Luigi.
I need to return to some mayoral duties.
So I'll be seeing you around.
Mario!
Bro!
You finally made it to New Donk City!
I was wondering when you get here.
I would have waited for you to watch me battle Pauline.
She's on a strict schedule.
So I had to take my chance.
Hey, it feels like forever ago since we had a good battle.
Let's have one right now.
Are we actually gonna watch the Mario Bros battle each other for free?
What's Mario Team's B?
I mean, they don't both have at least five power stars?
Let me heal your body up before we do this.
Okay, thanks, Luigi.
They're already fully healed, but like, you know, it's the thought that counts.
Let's go!
Oh, he has five mons now!
I wonder who it's his fifth one.
The Chuck Stack.
It's been a while since we battled, Mario.
I'm excited!
Mamma Mia!
Alright, I'm gonna sit on it.
Even though they're bigger, they're still tiny as fuck.
Yeah, Chuck Stack did great.
He lasted like two seconds.
Good for you, Luigi.
Wait, who's Bubbles?
Okay, Bubbles is...
Yes.
Okay, Bubbles sounds like a water tank.
Alright.
Oh, I forgot you're still here.
This is your redemption arc, part five.
I gave you five chances.
This is...
I...
Oh my god.
Okay.
Good luck.
Alright.
Magical Leaf.
No other dragon has had many chances as you two.
Oh.
He's fire type.
Well then.
Oh, that's awkward.
Okay.
So.
Um.
Goodbye.
Alright.
Back to dad.
Look, his name was Bubbles!
You assume he's water!
Like, I don't understand.
Like, you would think he's water.
Cause he's, like, his name was Bubbles.
I said...
How did I set him up for failure?
I saw the name Bubbles!
It's fire and water.
Who...
Why would anyone think, like, fire and water would be the combination for types?
It's fire and water.
It's like oil.
Oil and water.
Alright.
No.
Silly me for trying to send someone out that's not dad.
Alright.
Now sit on him.
Because it's cool.
What is this fucking Spongebob?
Fire and water?
Alright.
Private.
Doesn't matter.
He only has two mons left.
Now sit on him.
Oh shit.
He also has acrobatic.
Oh fuck that.
What?
That had so much HP!
Okay.
We'll just send in a fucking giant T-Rex in New Donk City.
He sat on me.
Alright.
Dragon tail.
No way does that match much damage.
There you go.
Stupid fucking acrobatic.
What the heck?
Oh he sent in another Yoshi...
Yoshi...
Yoshi Seros?
Aww.
Luigi couldn't have his own Yoshi.
So he like...
Just...
He just named one after Yoshi.
That's so sad.
That's actually so sad.
Yeah.
Oh dragon tail.
Oh it swaps...
I didn't know that.
I didn't realize it swaps out the mod.
I'm pretty sure it is dragon.
He...
He looked...
He named it after Yoshi.
Holy shit.
There's no way he can bulldoze my T-Rex.
He's much bigger than him.
Get out of here.
Oh he wasn't dragon type.
Alright.
You know what?
I'll send in Yoshi.
I'll send in you guys.
Dragoons.
Come on.
End it for me.
End this dragon.
You know what you wanna do?
It's all up to you.
Now lick him.
Oh shit.
End it with a lick.
That's right.
Now do it again.
Why are you like this?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki from the last Mario mod.
I looked up the last comic.
I was an hour into reading.
Thinking it was a short comic.
You're trying to read the entire...
I hope you're stronger than all of us.
I can't believe you're trying to read the entire comic series.
That's absolutely insane.
That shit is so bad.
Bro, there's no way you lose to Pauline.
Wow, bro.
You sure are strong.
Miss Pauline is going to be no match for you.
Say, have you seen Bowser around?
My new best friend?
I got to Newtong City and haven't seen him anywhere.
I'm sure he's not up to any trouble.
I've been teaching him the power of friendship.
Oh, you guys know there's like a very popular ship with Bowser and Luigi.
I literally taught him how to move return.
Anyway, Newtong City is really big.
So I'm going to explore a bit before moving on to World 7.
Later, bro.
Yay, I did it.
Okay, we got here.
Oh, he's calling me.
Excuse me, I have to take this.
The line has been picked by the apple.
No, it's not dumb.
It makes sense.
I mean, I'm having toilet troubles.
I'll be in the sewers.
Immediately.
All right, let's see.
Someone was like, I only know Bowser and Peach.
Oh, you poor, innocent soul.
You sweet, innocent soul.
I wish I have your innocence.
I've seen things.
I was on Tumblr during his peak.
I've seen so many things.
Mayor Pauline's steel-type captures are scary.
Make sure you bring some fire-types to melt them.
Oh, good thing I have dead.
I'm going to have to revalue my cap trainers.
So watch this online after that one.
You'll stay consistent, won't you, Mario?
A lot of people...
Oh, yeah, I already read that.
I traveled to the Metro Kingdom from Tostolina in order to complain about the pipe issue.
But now I don't want to leave.
Oh, there's a secret behind here?
What's the secret?
There's no secret, you lies.
All right, no secret here.
What do you mean?
Oh, middle top?
Here?
Oh, look up.
Oh!
Maya!
Oh, fuck.
Not him.
Maya, it's me!
Captain Toad!
That's me!
You here of all places, huh?
I know something from me to you!
Okay, the catching shot.
I was like, no!
Not him!
Bobby, you can share new captures.
You're probably pretty great, am I right?
Well then!
I'll be continuing on my journey!
Okay, thank god.
Okay.
Interactions with him was minimal, thank god.
All right, what is this?
A charm that raises...
the chance of critical capture?
But how do I use this, though?
Oh!
Wait, what?
How do I use this charm?
I don't know how to use it.
Oh, it's a passive.
Oh, so I just have...
So it just works.
You know what are the other guys saying?
I have for...
I have to have...
I can't melt steel beams.
Dang it!
Probably went and lost to your friend of all people?
What a battle!
What did you really get?
Okay, I won.
What the fuck?
I won and they're still glazing Luigi.
Going somewhere, chum?
Oh, no, don't.
Oh, no.
Oh, wait.
They're back.
You're coming.
Oh, it's the low sharks!
That's right.
I'm not scared of you.
You think I'm scared of you guys?
I beat you up last time.
Now then, you should know what we want from you.
No!
I'm a strong, independent Italian plumber.
I'm very smart, pal.
Now we gotta teach you a lesson.
That's right.
I'm not afraid of you.
I know you can bleed.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
That's a little bit of a problem.
Wait.
Okay.
They're both pretty big.
That's a little bit.
Okay.
No, that's fine.
That's fine.
It still works.
Okay.
He missed.
Don't worry.
It still works.
Omni, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
If you toss Bowser in Super Mario 64, how far do you think you could get her?
Um...
Why would I do it when I could pay someone else to do it?
I gotta delegate.
It's all about delegation, guys.
You think I have time for that shit?
I think people will do it for free, too.
It's all about delegation.
Alright.
Nice.
Bye, Strudan.
Why the fuck did he not hit him at all?
Like, I just need to hit one attack.
Definitely.
Oh, wait.
I still have the other...
Oh, what the fuck?
Histocrat.
Oh, my God.
He's so fat.
Okay.
I almost...
I almost used...
I almost used a really bad move.
Okay.
I'll just fly.
Flew up too high.
Alright.
Get out of here.
Yeah.
Easy.
Oh, he missed?
What?
Like, I just closed my eyes?
Like, how do you miss that?
He's in the sky.
You can barely see him.
How...
How can you get intimidated by someone in the sky?
All right.
Goodbye, Chain Chomp.
Bye.
That's fucking right.
Fire's good against steel.
I just learned that from that one random toad.
Okay.
I think I can sit on it.
I'll just magnet bomb this.
He's just floating there, menacingly.
He's still scared.
Like, what?
He just squints and sees him?
And, like, be like, oh, my God.
Like...
He sort of vaguely looks scary if I squint hard enough.
Yeah.
Meteor mash.
Oh, wait.
Do I send in, like, a meteor down?
Fire's a mirror-like punch.
May raise attack.
Okay.
60.
Oh, wait.
It's steel.
Okay.
I'm getting rid of rock throw.
Rock throw was a fucking mistake of a move.
Yay.
Goodbye.
You stupid plumber.
Boss, we're sorry.
That's right.
I bet you think you're so smart, plumber.
All you do is delay the inevitable.
All right.
Don't think I forgot.
You've had one...
Five too many chances.
Get in here.
All right.
You don't get this.
You don't get the VIP box either.
You and him.
Can spend your life here.
Together.
All right.
What the fuck?
What was this?
How did he get here?
Oh, Husky.
Oh, yeah.
You fucked up too.
Don't think I forgot.
All right.
There you go.
Let's see.
Who should we get to replace him?
You know what?
It's time for a hero to return.
It's time.
It's time for the hero to return.
Back to its roots.
Oh, wait.
We got another one.
I almost forgot about you.
There you go.
Well, called out of retirement.
One last job.
All right.
We got to heal real quick.
Ami, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Would you choose someone to throw a mint based on how far they could toss her or how low they were willing to be paid for it?
No, I'm gonna...
No, you'll pay me.
I don't think you guys realize that.
But, like, I know...
I will auction it off.
You'll pay me to throw a mint off.
Welcome.
This is Newtong City Hall.
Lady Pauline is just up ahead.
Repel and a challenger.
Be aware she used steel-type captures.
That Koopa Troop patrol on the other side of the room.
What's this game?
What can a proud...
Oh, sorry.
What can a proud Koopa Troop admin not get some relaxation around here?
Isn't Lady Pauline sing just the best?
I could stay here and listen to her forever.
Mario, it's so wonderful to see you again.
And also, wonderful timing.
I have a favor to ask you.
Well, actually two.
First, I can't seem to find my microphone all of a sudden.
I like to do a show while battling for power stars.
But without my microphone, the show can't start.
Mind helping me?
Great.
Now, the second issue.
Our sewer systems are having some unusual backups.
We hired some plumbers.
But they seem to be busy with other jobs.
I know.
I'm asking for a lot.
But I'll reward you handsomely if you do both.
Oh my god, guys.
I think she wants to get back together.
I say delusionally.
You should be able to get into the sewage through the manhole to the west of town.
Come see me when you're done.
Alright.
Oh my god, guys.
I think she still wants me.
I knew it.
I knew this relationship was not over.
It's salvageable.
Yeah.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You should auction it off to the west instead of us.
You'd make way more.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's right, bitch.
Oh, there must be wild mons here.
What the f- Oh my god, it's that guy.
Yeah, this fucking freak.
I forgot about this fucking freak.
Alright, baseball cap.
She wants me so bad, guys.
I can feel it.
Alright, I'm just gonna use capture.
If this doesn't work, I'll just send in...
Alright, we'll send in...
We'll send in the usual crew.
Get in there, Dragoon.
The usual.
It was boring this way.
You gotta get those fucking tumors checked out, that's for sure.
Alright, lick it.
Oh shit, that's not a lot of damage.
Alright, maybe bite it?
Alright, keep biting.
Just make sure you avoid the...
The little...
Sack...
Sack fluids.
Alright.
Alright, who wants to be the...
Oh wait, never mind.
I almost had him.
Okay, let me bite him again.
Alright, there we go.
What game is he from?
Jesus, what the fuck did he do?
Did he spit on me?
Sorry, spit on you guys?
What?
Get in here!
Oh my god, he literally showed up to me in Sire moveset and he's still not in the cap.
Oh, is it Mario Galaxy?
Oh, I never played Super Mario Galaxy.
Yay!
Alright, who wants to be the freak?
It's a lot of freaky moves.
Giant three-eyed spider.
It's a spider?
What?
That does not look like a spider.
And folklore is associated with outer space.
It draws acid and crafts on...
Skippa, skippa.
Made of an unusual sticky type silk.
Alright.
It's uglier...
This is him...
Prettier?
This is his glow up?
Alright.
You know what?
I'm gonna give it to 9-0 because he said it's uglier in Super Mario Galaxy.
9-0-goon.
Alright, let's see.
Are you the plumber lady, Pauline Contracted?
It's not time someone showed up.
Now listen up.
Right now, there's no water coming out of the pipes.
These vows make the water flow out of the pipes.
Simple, right?
Sadly, it's not that easy.
Members of the Cooper Troops are blocking access to vows.
That's where you come in.
Now get out there and don't disappoint lady, Pauline.
Okay.
I'll just grab these water out for now.
Oh, and then I can...
Oh, and then I can ride the shells.
And I can also break this.
Alright.
So I can swim.
Swim!
I swear to God.
If I can stick fuck in the sewers, I swear to fucking God.
What are you doing in the sewers?
Alright, let's see if I can encounter any mons here first.
Hello?
Is there no mons?
Where are all the mons?
Aw, it's a cheap chum.
I think I already have enough in my club.
Alright, let's see.
I guess I can't encounter any here.
Okay, none of these are like...
None of these are like...
Mons I have...
I don't have.
Wait, what?
He won't let me leave?
Let me leave!
Okay, there you go.
Orca, thank you, my super chat.
Thank you.
I'm poor, but I bet my friend next week can afford this auction in my name.
Name your price and she will pay.
It's an auction.
It can go to however amount it wants to go.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Mario, how'd you get down here?
Nice birthday for fishing, huh?
Alright, clubber.
Alright, get out of here.
That's right.
Get out of here!
You think you could take on Dad?
Manny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Not Doki, ping, ping out Min for a chance to chuck her into the sun.
I won't say pimping.
I would say it's an investment.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yay!
No, it's an investment, guys.
It's different.
Okay, I got water for this area.
Ba-dum.
Ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum.
Okay, tough puff.
It's a cloud.
Get out of here.
Alright.
Any new mods?
Oh, it's spiked up!
Yay!
Just as I was asking for new mods.
Oh, that was easy.
Yay!
Alright.
It's upside down.
It's like a little thumbtack.
A turtle with a single large spike on its shell.
The spike length indicates its status.
It crawls on ceilings to ambush prey with a drop attack.
Alright, who wants to be spiked up?
Alright.
Uh...
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-da-dum.
Ba-da-da-da-da-da.
Yeah, he's such a little...
There he is.
He's like a little thumbtack that you want to just...
Oh, it's like a spiky nipple.
Okay, let's see.
Uh, I'll give it a blaze...
Alright.
Blaze...
Ooh.
Some...
Wait.
Oh, you get to be in a club.
Blaze...
Good.
I know some goons might be into that.
Alright, where are you?
Oh, wait, yes!
Yes!
Okay, yeah, that's perfect actually.
You're in the right spot.
Think you're fixing the pipes, eh?
Not on my watch.
The implication.
Doki, what do you mean by the implication?
Alright, yay!
It's so easy.
I actually looked away and just smashed A.
I literally just hydrated knowing that dad will finish the job.
I've never seen this guy before.
Doki, this is not right.
What do you mean?
Just bros being bros.
Yay!
How do I get to that side though?
Oh.
Okay, clearly there's a pipe.
Here?
Oh no, it's on this side.
Okay.
So then the water should be hot.
Oh, so now I get the other side of the water.
Going somewhere?
Oh, it's a nice star bag.
Okay, this guy actually hurts though.
Actually hurts dad.
Oh, he flattered me!
Never mind!
You're such a... you're such a cool guy.
Wow.
I know.
I'm just so amazing and awesome.
And wowee.
Wow, Doki.
You totally deserve a million subscribers.
Yay!
A lubba?
What the fuck is that?
Sit on it.
I don't know what it is, but I want you to sit on it.
Jesus Christ, he's fucking tanky.
That took like forever for the HP to go down.
Okay, virus.
Acid armor?
Omni, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
About the auction and throw mint.
Like, geez.
Bowser and Super Mario 64.
Are you saying we only get to toss her once?
I mean, I could hold the auction every year.
It's like free money.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Try attack?
What's it gonna do?
Oh, oh.
Oh, that's a...
Oh.
It does nothing still.
Yeah, it practically prints money.
It's just a business.
Okay.
I mean, he lost.
Why are you laughing?
No, I'm too lazy to...
I'm too lazy to...
Go back to heal.
Go back to the Pokemon Center.
There has to be something that heals.
What heals?
Paralyze.
What can...
You know, paralyze stuff.
Electric seed.
Oh, full heal.
I'll just use full heal.
Fuck it.
There you go.
Next seed.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's Trophy.
Absolutely.
Oh my god.
A fucking course.
It's a stick bug.
You'd like...
This is like all you do.
This is literally all you do.
You have no life.
Mario found the long thingy thing for...
Oh, nice.
It's a long thingy thing.
Get stick bugged.
That's all it does.
Oh, wait.
I don't have Swoop?
I thought I have him.
All I have is like baby brother.
That's right.
I have your baby brother.
If you want to see him again.
Y'all get in this cap.
Next seed.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's true.
I'll pay handsomely the throw mint.
Yay.
All right.
Who wants to be Swoop?
Who wants to see their baby brother again?
Yay.
We're getting there.
We're almost at 50.
A noisy bat.
Its eyes are damaged from prolonged exposure to light.
It's a favorite's dark caves.
It produces a loud noise with powerful wing flaps.
All right.
Oh my god.
Come on, Dragoon.
Eat a little bit more.
Oh, you want to be the bat?
All right.
Okay, I hope you're not...
I hope you didn't trick me for getting two mons.
Because I actually forgot how many people I've named already.
Hey, where am I?
Oh, it's just like...
Oh, it's just more items.
All right.
Go back.
Let's go.
I love the music for this.
Oh my god, already.
He's just like...
He's just lining up.
They're like...
It's my turn to fight Mario!
All right.
I think it's this way.
Oh my god, I already forgot where I was.
Oh, here.
Oh, but there's a free item.
I love free items.
Super Syrup.
Yay!
All right.
Fight me.
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
Give me a sec.
I'm in a wild battle.
Not you!
But like, that's all right.
All right.
Now fight me.
Enemy spotted while on patrol.
Engaging now.
Mr. Blizzard.
Ooh.
All right.
Warm up those cheeks, dad.
Yay!
Oh yeah, dad's coming home in like...
Uh...
Three hours.
Yay!
We get to see dad.
Oh, I have some cute videos that the dog sitter sent me, guys.
I'll show that later.
I wanted to show a lot of stuff today, but like...
But like, I literally got back and then like, went to stream.
Sorry.
I couldn't prep anything at all.
I literally got back and just went straight to stream.
All right.
Get out of here, sumo bro!
Yay!
Oh wait, metronome?
Okay, that's a shitty move.
Get out.
Get that move out of here.
That's too RNG for me.
I'd like to know what's gonna happen.
Stop!
Lord, Bowser has restricted access to this pipe.
Well, I can't read, so I'm gonna go in anyway.
Oh, he only has one fucking...
Mon?
Bro, what the fuck?
You're fighting Mario and you...
Oh shit.
You're fighting Mario and you brought one move?
That's what's wrong with you.
Yay!
That's what you get.
That's what you get for bringing one fucking move.
Okay, did we catch all the mons in the sewers?
I can't tell.
Bro thought he was him.
I know.
Bro thought he was gonna be the one that beats Mario.
What did he do?
He momentumed me.
What is my...
Wait, what?
He died?
What?
What did he...
What did he do?
Alright.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh!
Chain Chomp!
Yes!
Okay, nice.
That's good, that's good.
Oh my god.
This has to be one of the rare encounters.
Because I haven't seen a Chain Chomp before.
Like, in the wild.
What is my clown ass lures?
At least I got Shadow Ball.
Oh my god!
Nice!
I don't have to try.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, I'm auctioning Chain Chomp out.
I'm...
This is my test run auction.
I know everybody wants to be a Chain Chomp.
A living wrecking ball.
Its loyalty to his trainer is unmatched.
Its leash is made of the strongest magnets known to exist in nature.
First try.
Alright, Chain Chomp is out.
I should be another dad.
No, dad is already perfect as he is.
I don't want to be that dog.
Oh my god, look at this fucking sprite, though.
He's like, hi.
It's really chinchom.
I'll be the girl.
He's going into the club.
Mehdi, Mehdi, you're ready.
You're ready.
You already have one.
And he's a good one, too.
Mehdi, you can't change your fate.
It was your destiny.
You can't change your destiny, Mehdi.
You have a child.
Think about your child, Mehdi.
But you can nominate a friend who has not yet been named.
You're a mom, Mehdi!
You can't just abandon.
Kida, thank you for the super chat.
Alright, we have $2.
We have $3.
$3.
$4.
Do I still have $4?
Do we have $10?
We have $10.
Bob from Bob.
Me, please.
I feel dirty.
$10.
We have $11 anywhere.
Anyway, $11.
$12?
Oh, we have $5.
That's below.
I'll call this one mint so you throw her and reel her back in.
Uh, next thing.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
$10.
$10 from Bob.
Going once.
Going twice.
And a $20 from... from...
$20 and Laffy.
From Laffy and Decree.
And Mehdi.
I'm a desperate man.
Give me.
I don't want to be a bother also make chop into Ipin.
From Mehdi and JL.
Me, thank you for super chat.
$20.
$20 fight.
Between Decree, Laffy, Mehdi.
Who dominates Ipin and JL.
$20.
We have $20.
We have $21.
$21.
It'll go to the first person that super chatted first.
The pin will get it first if he wins.
$21.
$21 from HoneyDragon.
Final bit.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
$22.
Do we have $22?
$22?
$23?
Maybe $25?
$25?
Alright.
Going... Let's up and up it.
$25 from Swiftstar.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
And then an Akasupa.
$100 from BBB Loony Bus.
With a high.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
The Akasupa with the chair.
We have an Akasupa.
And $5 added to the coin.
Sorry, JL.
You're a little too late, JL.
But thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
And $100.
Do we have $101?
$101?
$100 from BBB.
Going once.
Going twice.
Going 2.5.
And sold to BBB Loony Bus.
For the privilege of being named BBB Goon.
For Chain Chomp.
It's... Congratulations!
On being named BBB Goon!
Okay.
Let's go.
Congratulations to the auction winner!
And you're placed in the Goon Cave.
Alright.
Let me rearrange this.
Wait, Hefli.
Are you still?
Oh, we have fly.
Oh, wait.
I can actually fly with you.
Alright.
Let's see.
You are...
Okay.
Still fly.
That sucks.
Cause like...
Cause like, if I didn't have Lactiku, I would put you in my party.
Hahaha!
It's so funny.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Let's see.
I'll put you in...
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, sorry.
I can't... There's not enough... There's not enough... Okay.
There's not...
Okay.
Um...
Let's see.
Fun...
F-U-N-I-S-L-E-N-D... Okay.
Yeah.
It works.
Alright.
Here we go.
Don't worry.
Here.
This is a new... New area.
This is a new island.
I'll call it...
Fun Island.
Where everyone has so much fun.
Alright.
Fun Island.
Let's get...
Hahaha!
He failed.
No, no, no!
He didn't just get boxed.
He gets to be in the goon cave.
Hahaha!
Alright.
And...
And I'll let him...
Alright, B-B-B!
I'll let you pick.
Who do you want...
On the fun...
To have fun with?
Hahaha!
At the club!
You know what?
Maybe...
He's...
There you go.
You guys get to have fun.
Hahaha!
You get a pick.
You get to pick!
B-B-B!
For now I gave you...
I gave you...
I have a spoon for now, but you get to pick if you want.
Here are all the beautiful choices.
You know what?
There's so many squishy stuff that you can chomp here.
Here you go.
You can choose.
Yeah, I'm thinking about the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Look at all the options.
A variety you can chomp on.
Look at that.
Alright, let's go in.
Okay, let me roll around and see if there's any more...
Any more mons for me to catch?
Any victim is not...
Okay, then I think I made a good choice.
I think I made a... I think I made a good choice then.
You know what?
Just because you won the auction...
I'll let you out.
For one battle.
Alright, Heathley.
You can have some fun, too.
Here you go.
I gave you a Q-goon.
Joki-can, please come out of the box.
They make me clean the floor of my...
Thank you for the super chat, simple-minded.
Thank you, thank you.
Sorry.
Only one... Only one goon can be out of the box once a month.
You guys gotta share that.
Hello.
Talk to me.
The sewers aren't so bad.
There's space to run around like I just don't care!
Wahoo!
What do you mean fail?
It's a fun time!
Why would you ever want to leave the cave?
I worked so hard for you guys.
Providing for all of you in the cave.
To keep that cave running.
I can't believe you're complaining.
Oh my god.
Let me leave!
Sick bug!
I swear to god.
I'm gonna fucking sit on this.
Like...
What do you get out of this?
You're just gonna...
Oh my god.
You're so lucky.
There's no more pee pee.
Get out of here.
That's how weak you are!
I literally can just one-shot you on a move that's not very effective.
Nira, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, do you like your...
Do you like fun island?
It's so fun.
I forgot.
Was there anything back there?
Or was I just...
Was I seeing things?
Okay, I was seeing things.
I was...
I gotta go this way then.
Maybe Bowser will heal me.
He's known to be like a good person, right?
Alright, let's see.
Oh!
Wait, I didn't see that guy!
You didn't see me?
Oh yeah, I...
Yeah, I definitely didn't.
Alright, fishbone.
Oh wait!
I don't think I can...
Can I hit him?
I can't hit him, right?
Oh no.
I don't think I can.
Alright, I'll send in...
Yeah, he's a ghost.
Okay, I'll send in the dinosaur.
Yeah.
I was gonna say, he's a ghost.
Alright, I'll just hit him with my tail.
Dragon tail!
Okay, fucker.
Alright, move abuser.
It's not fair.
He's faster than a dinosaur!
It's not fair!
Get out of here!
You fucking fish!
Alright, what's next?
Evil?
That's right.
Try to heave me?
Say that to my...
Oh wait, you're stronger than the tail.
Never mind.
What?
Who did he send out?
Oh my god, get stick bug.
Alright.
Of course.
I was like, who did he send out?
Oh, the fucking stick bug.
That sucker punch.
Oh, I don't know what it does.
Alright.
Okay guys, was that obvious?
I didn't know what sucker punch did?
Get stick bug.
Yeah!
Okay, who did he send?
Alright.
That's good.
That's how I always want to end my battles.
Only does that little damage?
That's okay.
It's about sending a message.
It's...
Oh shit, never mind.
Let me actually make you use a real move.
Never mind, you might die.
My surprise attack.
Worthless!
That's fucking right.
You're so lucky dad doesn't have any more PP and heat crush.
Oh!
He's from Luigi's Mansion!
Oh, this has to be a rare encounter.
I haven't seen this guy before.
At all.
Yeah, Luigi Mansion Ghost.
Oh my god, that's a lot.
Okay, let me...
Alright, goodbye.
What level is he?
Your sacrifice will not be in vain.
Don't worry, BB Coot.
You just can't...
You're here to...
Look at that.
You're here to protect dad.
What a great honor.
Look at that!
See?
I told you!
You live!
You guys didn't believe.
I saw you guys saying, Bye, BB Goon.
You didn't believe.
A large ghost is known to strike the floor, making a racket and creating a shockwave attack.
Strangely, as a fear of high-isode vacuum cleaners.
Alright, who wants to be a...
Twirler?
From Luigi Mansion.
Alright.
Who has not...
Who has not been named yet?
Let's see...
Alright, just cause you said please.
Alright.
Welsh.
Oh my god, he's Welsh too.
Goon.
Alright.
I was placed in the Goon cave.
Okay, we got a helmet cap.
Can I turn this on?
Oh, I can.
Nice.
I dropped to my knees.
Oh wait, there's like a puzzle over there.
It's a fucking stick bug.
God, dammit.
Okay, dad is like hanging by the thread right now.
Oh.
Oh, I found the short gizmo thing.
Okay, I might have to heal him.
I don't think I'm gonna get...
Have like...
I don't think I'm gonna find any extra heals.
Do I have heals?
Paralyzed heal.
Oh, I have paralyzed heal.
Whoops.
Okay, that's awkward.
Oh, there you go.
Max mushroom.
Alright.
Nice.
I swear to God, if I bump into a...
If I bump into a...
A toad, that's like...
Let me heal you real quick.
I swear to fucking God.
Oh no.
Mario actually got here?
Okay, jabby.
This guy fucking suck.
I hate that guy.
This guy took like...
25 balls to like...
Oh, it's not very effective?
No.
No!
I just healed you!
Okay.
Bryce.
Um...
Ooh.
You have like...
A very interesting moveset.
Child ball.
Yay!
Wait!
No!
I...
Anytime I feel confident.
Alright.
Dream punch.
Every time.
Every time I start believing.
Okay.
Goodbye.
Is that all he knows?
Is that actually all he knows?
Does he...
He just knows how to whirlwind.
Get stick pug.
Alright.
Just stomp him.
He's just living by a thread now.
What is this?
Striker smack?
He's literally just a mascot.
So like...
Does it really matter what move he has?
Skitter smack.
These are skitters behind foes.
Lower...
Okay.
Yeah.
Let's get bite out of here.
You're just a mascot stick pug.
Like...
You have no purpose on my team.
Yeah.
Banto.
Okay.
That's...
Ghost.
That's be ghost.
Oh yeah.
It's a mask.
Can't have...
Oh shit.
Wait.
Doesn't...
Oh fuck.
Okay.
Oh shit.
No.
Wait.
I can stomp on him.
Nice.
We crunch him too.
Okay.
What are your move sets?
They do nothing.
Oh, it's not very effective.
Okay.
Oh, now they do something.
Oh, it's dark fairy.
Oh.
I thought it was like a little...
It was a ghost.
Because it says Banto.
Can I bribe you to fix Rice's moveset?
I feel bad for him.
Thank you for the super chat.
Nextie.
Thank you.
I can't fix something that's sort of already...
Like, unfair...
It's not my fault.
He doesn't have the moveset.
I...
What can I do?
Like, what can I...
Like, that's all they have.
That's all the moves they have.
What can I do?
Okay, it's 75% accuracy though.
So I don't know if that's worth it.
But it does have 100% power.
Swings tail...
It's tails...
Hmm...
Alright.
Swings tail to attack.
One, two, and poof.
From the mid and nextie.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh yay!
Everyone leveled up!
Yay!
Okay, he gets an attack later on.
See?
Look!
He is fixable!
Look at that!
You just gotta believe!
He's fixable, guys!
Alright, let's...
Open this again.
Alright, clearly...
There's something over here.
Oh my god!
Does he kill me?
Okay, he just goes...
Little places make this all more fun!
Polly just gave me a car!
Good luck!
I don't know anything about the pipes, so it's on you!
Okay, I don't know either.
Oh no!
Okay, I'm...
I'm so confused.
Alright, let's just grab items first.
I think I caught all the mons, right?
Guys, you guys know if there's any mons I'm missing?
From the sewers?
Yeah, I got Twirler.
Man, I'm so lost!
Guess I'm missing dinner tonight!
Does this say...?
I don't think it does.
I don't think it tells me like how many mons I have left here.
I haven't fished for one more that I haven't caught yet?
Alright.
Bet.
Alright, it's Cheap Chomp.
We have that.
Alright, is there anything else?
Okay, we'll do two more fishing.
Fishbone, we got that.
What?
Oh my god.
He knows.
Wait, if he's dived down, then I can run away while he's...
Oh my god.
I was gonna say, maybe I can run away while he's in the water.
How would he know?
Holy fuck!
How do you...
I'm 20 levels higher than you!
Okay, there we go.
Alright, last one.
God dammit, it's all the fish bones.
It's all dead fish and...
fish with lips.
Alright.
No more.
What does this do?
Oh, it resets everything.
Huh?
Oh, I did it!
Yay!
It's just that easy.
Look at that.
I don't know what I did.
Yay!
What did I do?
I don't know.
But I did it.
Mario?
You can't go any further.
Lord Bowser's in the middle of an important recital.
First try.
Let's go.
Oh shit, I keep forgetting.
Wait, he survived that?
Oh yeah, I forgot.
There wasn't a heat crush.
Nice.
Yeah, he's a bit bulky too.
I mean, he's literally a football player.
Alright, get out of here.
That's fucky, right?
Get out of here.
Let me use all my good moves on this lowly grunt before I fight Bowser.
No one can understand this mind.
Let her cook.
Banzai Bullet Bill.
It's the same one.
What makes him different from the other Bullet Bills?
He looks a little angrier?
He painted an angrier expression.
Lord Bowser isn't gonna like this.
Alright, I'll do one more fishing.
I'll do one more and see if I can get it.
Whatever it is.
God damn it, it's just fishbone.
Alright, no more.
No more fishing.
Sometimes it's not a nice day for fishing.
Minions!
Oh my god, he's gonna sing Pinky Peaches!
Our plan for utter domination is nearing its end.
Soon, Luigi will claim all his power stars.
And we'll steal them from him so I can have a wish for myself.
Comics should still be starting Mario in the Sand Kingdom.
Giving us ample time to celebrate.
We have all been wonderful followers.
And I feel now is the best time to show my gratitude.
Minions!
This one is all for you!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, it's Jack Black Bowser!
I knew it!
Just like Seth Rogen Donkey Kong!
Oh my god, it's so beautiful.
Mario, did nobody else see you come in?
However, we're all busy listening to Lord Bowser anyway.
Oh my god, it's beautiful.
Oh, you got Lord Bowser!
Lord Bowser is so good at the piano.
I could listen forever.
Peaches...
Alright, it's enough.
Are we on stage?
We were definitely upset.
Bowser, okay...
Okay, now I can make him angry.
Yeah, I recognize the chorus.
Mario, how dare you interrupt my performance?
Minions, on the stage!
I'm not even done with the B section.
Let my song power you up, my minions.
I'll take care of this, Lord Bowser.
That's right.
Oh my god, and I get the beautiful Peaches background music on the side.
Oh my god, he's so empowered!
Oh my god!
With the power of music!
Too bad he's just gonna get flipped!
That's right, get out of here!
Power of music won't save you.
That's right!
Oh shit, no, not acrobatic.
Okay, that attack actually is pretty strong.
Oh my god!
And a coo- Okay, that's a little awkward.
That's- Ooh, that's a little- Oh, that's a little- Guys, I think I might- I should have healed.
I-
Oh, that's awkward.
Okay, do you think they'll heal me?
Oh, guys, the power of music is a little strong.
Holy shit!
It's okay, Ryze, you got this.
Who would've thought...
The power of music.
Oh my god, he's just using one move!
Okay, nice.
Okay, that's okay.
Ryze, you can redeem yourself here.
Sick butt, this is your moment.
It's okay, I think Ryze can live this.
Sorry, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's all downhill from here.
That's okay, we'll get healed here, right?
Like, I'll get healed here, right, guys?
What does bulk up do?
Oh, nothing.
It's not an attack.
Not an attack equals not learn.
How's Mario always so strong?
Hey, guys.
Can I get healed?
Guys, a little heal there.
Guys?
Guys, how about a little heal here?
What happened to all the heals?
No heal, only attack.
Can you heal?
Maybe not.
Does it look like I have...
Oh, hey!
Oh, yes!
Okay, that's good.
Okay, it's okay.
Dad, you're back.
Come back here.
That's fine.
Okay, we got this.
No heal, at least.
Only Lord balance your music.
All right, die for the cause.
It's okay.
You did great.
You did good, BBBoon.
You did good.
Okay, that's okay.
Like, that's okay.
I didn't realize that also does that.
That's okay.
You know what?
Get stick bugged.
That's right.
All right.
Maybe that does a lot.
Oh, yay!
It does!
Oh, okay.
That's fine.
Okay, yeah.
All right, dad.
Get back in here.
He's back.
He's back with milk, guys.
He came back with milk.
Oh, God.
Okay.
I have, like, five.
It's okay.
I have the final move.
That will save us all when we need it.
Wah!
Whatever.
Surgeon Guy will take care of you.
Don't worry, men.
I'll take down Mario.
That's right.
You and what army?
It's okay.
We have four moves to make it count.
Four PP moves.
Five, actually, in the end.
I have a secret...
I have a secret move right here.
Oh, never mind.
I still have my secret move.
No, my money!
It's okay.
I still have my secret move.
Nice.
Peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches.
Peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches.
How do you miss?
He's right there!
Oh my god.
Alright.
This is awkward.
Okay, he's hit with everything, but that's okay.
You got this, dad.
We might have to cut off your toes.
To prevent...
We might have to cut off your toes because you have frostbite, but that's okay.
Alright, Bowser.
We're...
No match for Mario.
We're sorry.
But keep playing.
Thank you, everyone.
Now then, I think it's time we meet up with Comic to discuss our next course of action.
You may know our plan now, but that doesn't mean we're going to stop.
Tell Luigi whatever you want.
He's too naive to think otherwise.
Oh, and I think I'm finally starting to enjoy this game.
Ha ha ha.
Oh, and I don't need this anymore.
Oh, I got the microphone.
Yay.
Wait, I live.
Wait, what?
Oh, it's a chopper piano from Super Mario 64.
Mad piano.
He's mad now.
It's okay.
I got a baseball cap.
Okay, he's strong.
Okay, this is bad.
Oh, no.
Okay.
Oh, it's not very effective.
Oh, but I have frostbite.
I forgot.
That's okay.
I'm going to see how...
Maybe.
I might be lucky.
Yay!
Oh, fuck.
Never mind.
He...
He tricked me.
Dad, you can live through this.
I believe, Dad!
Dad!
Dad, come on!
No!
Oh, no.
Ooh.
Whoa.
It's okay.
We can catch this.
We...
All right.
Okay.
We have a dream lineup.
It's okay.
It's...
I believe.
I believe in us.
Oh, my God.
It doesn't affect them.
Get stick bugged.
Oh!
I still believe.
It's still possible.
It's still...
Okay.
That's good.
We're still in this.
We're still...
Oh, shit.
Okay.
We're still in this.
I'm risking it.
Yes!
Oh, I got a critical catch!
Oh, that was close!
That was so close!
That was actually so close!
A piano that gained sentience while inside a ghost house.
Rumors say that feasts on the souls of those scares.
It's surprisingly in tune.
Oh, Xeon!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I don't know what's gonna happen, but I'd like to be the piano regardless.
Alright.
Okay, you don't have another Mon, right?
I swear to God.
Don't take advantage of the fact that we've named so many that I forgot which ones people actually have now.
Xeon Goon.
Oh, wait.
Yes, he should be in the Goon Cave.
Alright.
No, he should be, like, here.
Oh, where's the other guy?
Oh, yeah.
Alright.
BBB, you've had your time.
Now you can be a- You know what?
Now you can be a- Now you can be a, um...
Be on the top now.
Ha- ha- ha- ha- ha- ha.
Alright.
Seems like, yeah, I'll take it.
I gotta get healed anyway.
Okay.
Where am I?
Oh, here I am.
Great job, Osiris!
Now we can finally get back to our everyday lives!
Oh, I have all the stuff.
So, I'll give you something.
I'll give to all my minions.
Oh, I got the Naughty Mint.
Wait, what?
I cannot know when I'll see you again, man in red and blue.
My hope is when I'm still... I mean, landed on the... Wait, what?
What is that?
Oh, wait.
Can be smelled.
It ups attacks but reduces... Oh, okay.
Okay, it's not as bad.
Okay, guys, it's not that bad, guys.
It can be smelled and it ups attack.
Okay.
Naughty Mint.
I got a little worried there.
I was like, what do you mean, Naughty Mint?
Oh, it lets me change nature.
Oh, that's interesting.
Sniff on... No, I didn't say that!
Wait, how do I... Oh, there we go.
Yoshi's Whistle.
I keep forgetting to use the Yoshi.
Alright, we got the microphone.
We can fight Pauline now.
We finally get our fucking other power star.
Mario.
I don't know what you did, but all the toilets in New York City can flush again.
How do I know that?
I'm just a little mayor's intuition.
And thanks for getting my microphone back.
With this, we can finally get the show on the road.
You ready?
Give it all you got, Mario.
Oh my gosh, she's so into me, guys.
She wants to get back together.
Guys, I broke up with her.
Okay?
It's not the other way.
Despite what the rumors say.
I was the one that broke up with her.
And look at that.
Now she's crawled.
She wants to crawl back to me.
Oh my god.
He's so strong.
What the fuck?
Okay, critical hit.
Nice.
Cool.
Shit.
I'm not even through the first verse yet.
I would have thought that would be like...
You know, what was it called?
What was that?
The famous song in that game?
I remember the song.
What was it called?
The title of that song?
Yeah, Jump Up Superstar.
Yeah, I assumed the song playing would be Jump Up Superstar.
Since it's Pauline.
That's fine.
That's right.
Get out of here, Chain Chomp.
Yeah, it would have been a nice touch.
I mean, it's just little things.
Because already, it's like pretty good.
Okay.
A charge that we burn...
The foe also hurts the user.
Okay, I don't want to like hurt himself.
Fuck.
Okay.
No, we gotta keep this.
What?
Guys!
Explosion, though!
Okay, we get rid of one of the fight moves, though.
Dad does not want...
Doki does not want Dad to hurt herself.
She says that she still keeps...
Explosion.
No, but he crashed has been...
He crashed has been so good to me!
Cross chop?
All right, cross chop.
Okay.
We gotta keep Explosion all the way to the end!
We start with Explosion!
We end with Explosion!
Comatose?
He's already sleepy?
He just started the game!
Goodbye!
That's right!
Get out of here!
Yes, I have!
Watch part 1 of MARIO MARIO MARIO MARIO MARIO!
We start with...
Self destruct!
We end with Explosion!
As it should be.
Alright, sit on it!
Yeah!
Oh shit, okay, I might die.
That's fine.
That's right, he'll live!
Watch this!
Yeah!
Holy fuck!
What an HP in the dream!
Okay, is he faster?
No ma- no, I think dad's faster.
There's no way.
Dad has to be faster.
I believe.
Yeah!
All in!
Gambo, Gambo!
One HP in a dream!
I liked my odds.
Never punish.
Great job, Mario!
Seems the audience loved our little show.
Now then, I believe this belongs to you.
Mario, you see the New Donk City Power Star?
Yay!
One HP is all he needs, guys.
Incredible Gambo.
Yay, I got a TM!
That contains Smart Strike, a move that will always strike true.
I hope you'll make good use of it in What Remains of Your Cap Challenge.
Hey, bro!
What a super battle!
I'll meet you outside, okay?
Yeah!
Okay, I got the plumber.
All right.
Oh, she so wants me.
Wow, great battle, bro.
Now, there's only two Power Stars left.
We've sure gone a long way from Toad Town, so we can't stop now.
Come on!
On to World 7!
Um...
Solid, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Female Doki voice acting sound pretty sweet.
Not that regular Doki is not sweet or anything.
Regular Doki is more gremlin-like.
I heard that the World 7 World Pipe is out of service.
Another one?
What's going on at the warp zone, bro?
What an easy job.
I could have done it without you.
Nothing is impossible when we work together.
Plus...
Oh my god!
They cut it in half?
This place has plenty of spare parts.
Wow!
Oh my god!
They cut the plum...
The fucking pipe in half!
I think I call in a favor.
Come with me.
Where is she taking me?
Oh my god.
Just a moment.
I gotta make a call real quick.
Hello?
Yeah, I got a couple of plumbers looking to make their way up to space.
What?
Oh, am I going to Rosalina?
Can you help us out?
Of course.
You too.
Wait.
No rainbow?
Guess she ran out of budget or something.
Anyway, this should take you all the way up to Comet Observatory.
Don't worry about the edge of the road.
You should fly up before you fall off.
But, Miss Pauline!
Don't have our...
We don't have our carts.
Can you order shop for the banana peeling?
Hmm.
I might have some extra carts in the garage.
Let me check.
Oh my god.
Guys, why pay $80 for Super Mario Kart World when I can play...
When I can do it here for free?
Hey, do standard modules work?
I don't see any B-dashers or Mach-8s.
Miss Pauline, you're too kind.
Whatever works for you.
Isn't this exciting, bro?
New carts!
Here you two are.
Be safe on the road.
Yay!
I got a standard cart!
You ready to leave?
Okay, I gotta heal first.
Dad is...
Despite how cool it was that we won with 1 HP on Dad...
I think we might need to heal him.
I feel like it might not be cool to keep him 1 HP.
Alright, get in here.
Oh yeah, you're right.
Well, I pay $80 when I can give...
When I can pay $90 for Sonic Racing instead.
And Hatsune Miku.
Nah, I don't need heals.
Yeah, I'm ready.
Last one to the comment.
So already mixed the spaghetti.
Three, two, one.
That's a photo finish.
We were all like Skirt and Kabloo.
Oh well, guess we'll never know who got a first place, bro.
By the way, I don't think Bowser and his goons are gonna follow us up here.
He's gonna be left behind in the race for the Power Stars.
I'm sure he has a plan to catch up.
We could just focus on ourselves here.
Oh, yes you should.
Welcome back to the Common Conservatory.
The two of you, before you challenge me, I only ask for two things.
These stars will take...
I love this song too.
This is like one of my favorite like study songs that I put on when I'm like working.
These stars will take you to planets where you'll collect silver stars.
Two on this planet, and three on this planet.
You'll need to challenge my Lumos for them.
Don't let their cuteness fool you.
They're quite the fighters.
When you get five silver stars, come back here to make it into the Warp Star.
Shooting you to the top of the spire, or you can challenge me.
But don't feel pressured to complete my quest so soon.
Feel free to explore around and talk to my Lumos.
They love the company.
Alright.
We're so close to finishing the challenge, but we can't stop now.
Well, whichever planet you go to, I'll go to the other one.
Let's meet up later.
Mamma mia.
And give it a...
I'll get the Shisafelion.
Thank you.
Welcome to the comet observatory.
Mario.
Mamma is waiting for you.
You should talk to her.
Okay, I need to get...
Uh...
Silver stars.
Oh, there's the items!
Nice!
Yoink!
My...
My loot now!
Are you going to take the launch star that's up ahead?
Make sure you're properly prepared before you do!
Mamma told me to sell you all sorts of things!
Oh wait, what do they have?
What do they have here?
Dora cat...
Mulaney?
Wait, a better cat with a higher catch rate than a plumber cat.
Okay, so...
Wait, I already...
I already have the best one though, so it's fine.
What can you take on my child?
Hmm, I don't know.
Come back once you collected all the power stars.
Later, Bluely must like my friend over here to sell stuff in order to help mama out.
Do they all have mommy issues?
I may not look like it, but I'm actually a scientist.
I like the research...
What kind of fucking science...
What...
What do you get out of bedtime stories?
No, I don't need heals.
I'm invincible.
Rosalina has a lot of bedtime stories in these bookshelves!
I'm not trying to read anymore because it's making me creepy!
Hey, Mario!
Have you seen our blue friend?
He's making her acting a little suspicious!
Have you seen him?
Do you even need to come back?
The library here in the Observatory has all sorts of information.
But if not that information is useful to you, it's a whole different story though.
Bio!
That means you love your team!
Oh, I could have just healed it up here.
Wait, those are actual kids?
Wait, how does she give birth to so many stars?
Wait, take a picture of me.
Yay!
Nice.
Wait, how does she...
Who's the dad?
We don't ask questions like that.
I'm just...
You said they're all our kids!
Mario!
Mama told me you're supposed to make good luck!
Yes!
The Toad doesn't notice you as it looks blissfully...
Oh, yeah, I'll nudge him.
Bye!
Toad was ejected.
That's right, as it should be.
Oh!
Oh, you can fight!
The fuck is that?
It's just a shape.
Or just a fucking shape.
Ma!
There's a weird shape in the backyard!
It's a fucking triangle in the backyard, Ma!
All right.
Get out here.
Ew, shapes.
What's he gonna do?
Fucking do trigonometry on me?
God damn it!
You're so low level!
Know your place!
Ma!
He's looking at me!
It's fucking weird!
Yeah!
All right.
Who wants to be the weird-ass triangle?
The mini-yucks.
Yay!
A creation from the X-knot army.
Meant to help out yucks.
Its shape makes it a sturdy foe.
This triangle is the best shape ever, period.
All right.
Let's see.
Depends.
Is Doritos hiring?
All right.
Let's see.
I'll give it to...
I'll give it to the person that looks...
Looks like a triangle the most.
Personally, I like circles more.
All right.
Min...
Min Goon.
This is your birthright.
That guy!
How dare you?
I thought space was traversable.
With the ship?
But there's no water here!
Sorry, I just realized it was a toad.
You can't deny what your birthright...
Okay, Ma-ra.
Okay, I feel like I should...
That looks like he's made of water.
You don't get to choose what you're born as.
Okay, I knew it.
I fucking knew you were a water type, you fucking whore.
I knew it.
All right.
You got this, Hefli.
Tank that.
I believe in you.
Okay, that you took a lot.
That was a lot of damage, but I still believed.
I was like...
Tank that soldier, boy.
Yay!
Wait, what is he about to use?
Oh, I didn't read in time.
Oh, there's like a Mario in the background.
I just noticed it.
Oh, fuck, it's fishbowl.
Whoops.
I should have read.
I was like, I don't know.
It can't be that important.
All right.
You're tanking this one.
That's right.
I brought a dinosaur.
Okay, and then I start crunching it.
Crunch him!
Oh my god.
I hate fish bones.
They're such pussies.
All they do is just dive.
That's all they do.
The dive spam.
Goddamn pussies.
I'm a fish out of water and space.
That's right.
What you doing bringing fishes in here?
Out in the water.
What's this?
Oh, it's a teepee.
Oh, I see.
Wait, there's grass here?
What the fuck?
Why is there grass here?
Oh, it's another mini yucks.
Okay, get out.
I gotta leave.
Bye.
Okay, is there anything good?
Space grass.
Yeah, I was gonna say, why is there...
Oh, there's the X-Knot!
Baseball cap.
Yay!
Thank god, I don't have to try for this.
All right, X-Knot time.
Just a little guy.
A loyal peon to Lord Crump.
Make me X-Knot and I am yours to command.
Zekra, thank you for the Akka soup.
But thank you, thank you.
You know how like...
Like there's always like one person who is a huge fan of the most obscure fucking thing ever?
Like that...
I was like, holy shit.
It's an X-Knot's number one fan right here.
It works better within a group.
So it's been a really effective party member for the cap challenge.
I am that fan.
It's an X-Knot has no fans.
I am dead.
Okay.
Zekra...
It's like that one girl that's like super obsessed with Stan...
Stan Marsh from South Park.
There's always one fan that makes it their whole life.
Oh, shit.
I just called him Zekra.
He is him!
Oh, there's a Luma!
He is Exxon.
Just so powerful.
He just stopped.
He's literally him.
Not even good anymore.
He's just is him.
What's your wish?
Your wish is...
You're already full HP.
Oh, shit.
I actually used Fedora.
Okay.
I don't remember which one was the stronger cap.
Oh, it's a helmet.
Okay.
Okay, we gotta use that.
Yeah, I ran out of baseball caps.
Oh, no.
I gotta buy more bait.
I'm gonna kidnap her child.
I'm gonna kidnap Rosalina's child.
Aww.
Okay, I actually have to...
I actually have to fight somebody.
I have to fight him.
Alright, get Stickbug.
That's right.
It's Stickbug time.
Okay, I...
I'm a little scared...
that he's gonna like kill her.
I'm gonna...
I'm a little scared that he might...
Oh.
Don't tell Rosalina.
Don't tell Rosalina what happened.
Don't tell her what happened.
No.
Quick, hide the body.
Quick.
Somebody...
It's okay.
We're in space.
I can chuck it out of the space.
And no one will know.
No one will know.
I'm so sad.
I think the Luma was actually a rare encounter.
No!
What's she gonna do?
Count every star?
She won't notice a missing child.
I'm so sad.
The Luma was actually a rare encounter.
I...
I didn't know!
How was I supposed to know my Stickbug was gonna fucking suck up train its life and then chuck it all into the test of space?
I love looking into the night sky.
So much, I had to come up to see the stars for myself.
I trained myself diligently to climb up, thinking it's gonna be as beautiful as I imagined.
And while it is, the longer I stay up here, the more I start to miss everyone that couldn't come with me.
Mario, make sure to tell everyone how much you love and appreciate them.
Cause even though the stars feel eternal, they're just as bleeding as everything else.
Do you think he knows I committed two murders out here?
Do you think he knows?
Do you think he knows I might have to commit a third murder?
Hahaha!
Sound about this area suspicious!
Is it you?
He knows what you are.
He knows too much, guys.
Hahaha!
Okay...
We didn't actually kidnap a child.
We didn't do it, guys.
There was no evidence a child ever existed.
Oh wait, it's the actual Duplicose.
Oh, never mind.
Oh wait, that's me.
That's right.
I'll throw myself out.
Get out of here.
Yay!
Alright, we gotta get...
We're so close to level 50 for Dragoon.
I'm so sad.
I can't believe...
Nice!
I won't make the same mistake.
Come here, child.
She won't notice.
You're gone.
There's so many of you guys.
She won't know.
It'll be our little secret.
Oh yeah, I can heal.
Nice.
Wait, what?
Okay.
Alright, Rice.
This is it.
Oh fuck, I forgot.
I forgot what you can do.
Wait, Rice, get out of here.
No!
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Okay, that's not an attack.
Okay, thank god.
Okay.
Okay, get out.
I just remember what you do.
I...
I just remember Perish.
Okay, there you go.
Alright.
This should be okay.
Oh, thank god.
Oh wait, it's super effective.
How?
The one...
This one move that I use as a meme is super effective now?
That's five.
Okay, good.
Alright.
It's one HP.
Yay!
We got Luma!
Nice!
Child!
Oh my god.
Wait, I think...
I think it's it.
I think it's time.
Wait, head charge.
Imagine...
A charge using...
It hurts the user a little.
Okay, we're gonna get rid of...
Mmm.
Okay.
I don't know.
Hurts the user a little bit.
Okay, we'll get rid of butt.
Alright, head charge.
Oh my god, it's time.
We got the twofer.
A star creature that loves to help everyone.
It comes in a variety of colors.
The most common is yellow.
Rosalina cares for it like it's her child.
See, it's not even her real kid.
Alright.
Doki kills Luna.
Boss, you killed a child!
Amazing work!
That right here is why you're the best boss.
That's the one and only Solid Snake.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yay!
We also adopted a Luma, guys.
We also...
There can only be one Star Goon.
Thank you for the super chat.
Star, thank you.
Thank you.
Demon, thank you for the super chat.
Oh, man.
I'm sorry, Demon.
But his name is literally Star.
It's like...
It's faded.
Star...
Don't worry, I'll name you or something else.
Yay!
Yay, we adopted a child, guys, together.
Oh my god, yes!
Yes!
Eat!
Dragoon, eat!
Why are you purple?
What happened?
Oh my god, what happened to you?
You're so ugly!
But you still love us, right?
I'm ruined!
Brokai into toxic waste!
What the fuck?
Space, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Papa, thank you for the super chat!
The prophecy has been fulfilled.
Mega, Chonky, Goon, Nixie, and Omni.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Aphelia, thank you for the super chat.
Can you rewind in this game?
Butter, please love us.
Butter, please.
Isn't this what you wanted, Butter?
I kept eating.
That's what you wanted.
We require your love, Butter.
Guys, I thought we were gonna get Big Yoshi.
Whatever.
I was tricked.
I thought I was gonna get Yoshi.
I got tricked.
You guys told me it'd be him.
I thought it'd be him.
Why can't you be like him?
Why can't you be like Yoshi went to med school?
Aww.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Peter.
You're like, why aren't you cute like him?
Like our neighbor?
Tinder profile picture versus IRL.
Why we did this, Butter?
We did this for you.
No, I got Yoshi from Team Move.
And his name is Yoube.
I got Yoube.
We have Yoshi at home.
What happened to you?
I was so happy.
You can never be him.
Is there a thing you were the same?
Who are you?
Who even are you?
What happened to her?
What happened to my Yoshi?
What did you do?
It's like those cuckoo birds shit.
Tlook it.
Oh no.
No.
I'm sorry.
I was so hungry.
I have one but you have to earn it.
Where does he even come from?
Where does you come from?
It's just, are you a cuckoo?
It's like those cuckoo birds that like, you know the cuckoo birds that like, they lay their eggs on, into like other birds' nests.
And then like, as they get older, like you can tell that they're like a lot bigger.
A lot bigger than like actual birds.
That's what you are.
That's what you turn up and I'm like, wait, what?
What?
We ate the real child.
What happened to my Yoshi?
What happened to him?
What did you do?
Momohaku, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What did you do to Yoshi?
What did you do to him?
Imagine being a dragon, you always wanted to be an evolving into that.
Alright, Sigma crew to level 49.
Wow, great job.
Here you go, as promised.
I got a silver star.
You told us to eat, Doki.
Oh my god.
Look at you.
I love us.
What did you do?
Wait, no.
I can't look at you anymore.
I spent so much of my time alone just like that.
Wait, don't worry.
Don't worry, guys.
Some info on you.
Appeared in Mario & Luigi prior to his time and was created by the shrews.
And literally ate the Yoshis on Yoshi's Island.
He got to go inside his belly.
No, don't worry, guys.
We can fix this.
Okay.
We can fix this, guys.
Do not worry.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
You just...
You need a rest, guys.
You guys need a rest.
You had such a long day.
I heard that some people have trouble breathing in space.
What's the issue?
It's not like you're breathing in anything bad.
You're just... You're just... You're just having a little break, guys.
You had a long day, everyone.
You all had such a long day.
Well, you see, it all started when I was disowned by my mother.
No, you guys all had such a long day.
You're so tired.
We're all so tired.
Francisca, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Chaz, don't get a Mexican mom.
Make us eat the whole plate and then disowning us.
No, you guys are so tired.
Dude, you...
You worked so hard, everyone.
That's a silver star.
If you only found one, you're gonna need two from this area.
I wanna get to mama's power star.
Wait, we'll take a launch here for now.
And then...
Let us...
Okay, where was...
Where did it say it was?
Warp pipe.
Okay, it was like...
Here, right?
Where was it?
Okay.
Okay, it's up here.
Alright.
Oh, it was the safari zone.
I remember.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, no, no.
You're just so tired, guys.
So very tired.
This guy rest after all the hard work.
I tried so hard and licked so much.
But in the end, it doesn't even matter.
It goes, thank you for the super chat.
No, no, no, no, no, guys.
No, no, no.
Everything is fine.
Delta, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Today in Mario, man.
Don't keep it disbalanced.
The track goes after they fall into a half a ton of fat dinosaurs.
A green triangle is named after a minute.
And the actual green triangle in chat is confused.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Champion, thank you for the super chat.
Yeah, you're just taking a little nap, guys.
You worked so hard to be here.
Just taking a little nap.
Why am I in the safari...
Don't worry about it.
About why I'm here.
Do not worry.
Wait, actually.
Wait a minute.
Why am I trying to get...
Okay.
Oh, wait.
I...
I forgot.
I, like...
Raised you from a...
No, no, no.
Don't worry about it.
No, no, no, no.
Don't worry.
It's okay.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Oh, that is...
What do you mean?
Oh, my God.
Yay.
Who's...
Nothing, guys.
Nothing, nothing, guys.
It's nobody.
It's no one.
It's no one, guys.
It's nobody.
It's...
It's no one.
Guys, don't worry about it.
Don't...
Don't worry about it, guys.
Don't worry about it.
It's no one.
It's nobody.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we did it, guys!
We reversed... We reversed the evolution!
Oh my god!
Look at that!
You're beautiful again!
Oh, you're beautiful, guys!
Look at you!
You're so beautiful!
Now we can actually level...
Now we can turn you into the Yoshi that we've always wanted you to be.
Yoshi!
Look at you!
Oh my god!
Dragoon!
Look at you!
You're so...
You're so cute, guys!
Look at you!
What do you mean?
You're so...
You're so cute, guys!
What high horsepower?
The fuck is that?
Lamsa... Oh shit!
Yeah, let's get that in.
Oh my god!
Look at you, Dragoon!
Now you're...
You're perfect!
Poor god!
Mr. Broken Pod!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
No, look!
You're beautiful!
Yes!
Look how beautiful you are!
I'm afraid!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
JL!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
It's just...
Oh wait!
Next thing, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I never thought I missed the days of licking things on combat.
CV, thank you to the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What did we learn today?
If the first shadow's not turned out correctly...
You just found them and replaced them with the...
No, there's no replacement going on here.
You guys, we're always yellow.
What are you talking about?
This is your true form, guys.
I'm always up from home up here.
Don't know what to do, but fight my way up.
What you guys always looked like, chat.
Our whole plan was to always make you a yellow Yoshi.
Because you're a dragoon.
And dragoons are yellow.
As you're silly.
Malou, you're lying to me.
Look, it's you!
It's like when they replaced Fat Tony.
Space, thank you with the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh shit, I wasn't looking.
Oh, quiet.
Wait, what?
What did he take from me?
This feels like a would you love me if I was a worm.
Welsh, thank you with the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, he's angry.
Nobody knows.
There was no crime.
Okay.
Yeah, throw him!
Alright, nice.
Was that maybe a bad decision?
Alright, we go this way.
We gotta get the other silver star.
Oh, there he is.
You're looking for a silver star?
Well, I have one.
I'll give it to you.
We can overcome my trial.
Except June 7th.
Never forget.
What are you guys talking about?
What happened on June 7th?
Oh, when we had such a great time playing Mario Mon, guys?
I licked my way into becoming you.
And all I got was a stupid box.
Oh, when...
Oh, when you guys...
When you guys evolved into Yellow Yoshi?
Oh yeah, that was a great time, guys.
That was a great time, everybody.
When you all evolved...
Oh my god.
Wow, great job.
Here you go, as promised.
Good times, good times.
Yes, good times.
yodhi is the redi Rand.
Busbol, thank you for the Super chat.
Thanks, thank you.
Yellow Yoshi is more meta than nube?
Apparently so.
I see this as an absolute win.
Lali, thank you for the Super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Purple Dragoon replaced by yellow Dracoon.
Didn't have cognitive still!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yay!
Never punished.
Just, you know, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The traitor.
Remember who you were, Simba.
Hey, those are silver stars.
Good job, Mario.
Mama will definitely be happy with those.
Alright, we'll go back now.
We have...
Okay, we gotta...
Okay, I have to...
I'm thinking I should buy more caps right now.
Alright, yeah, you know what, fuck it.
I'll buy more caps right now anyway.
Where was it?
Main Street?
Uh, oh yeah, here.
I think it was downtown.
Oh no, it wasn't.
It was...
here somewhere.
Where the fuck is that store?
I always get lost here.
Oh wait.
It's here, right?
This looks like a giant mall.
No.
Never mind.
Okay, it must be down here.
I remember it was like either upstairs or downstairs.
Okay, no.
That's the dance club.
Yeah, but like...
He sells like shitty caps though.
Wasn't like baseball caps stronger than the...
I don't remember.
Was the baseball cap stronger?
Or...
The...
Hard hat.
I couldn't...
Remember.
Helmet is stronger?
Oh!
It was?
Oh, okay.
I didn't realize.
I couldn't tell.
Okay, we'll go to...
We'll go back to Luma then.
Okay.
We'll put...
We'll go back into the sky!
Hmm.
Okay, let's see.
Alright.
Okay, fine guys.
We'll...
Fine.
Fine, guys.
We'll let...
We'll put...
Oh my god.
Nevermind.
I looked at him again and...
Cat, I looked at him again and...
Cat.
Okay, we can't have two dragons though.
We can't...
I'm sorry.
I'm broken.
Yeah.
You were a hero.
I'll let you have some fun.
Hahaha.
Alright.
Okay, but like...
If he has to be in the party...
If she has...
If he has...
Haha.
Hahaha.
There he has to...
Dragoon.
Hahaha.
Dot dot dot.
Dragoon.
Hahaha.
Hahahaha.
That...
Oh, you're right!
Wait, you're right!
Wait, you're right.
I like that.
Wait, I like that.
I like that too.
Hahaha.
Okay.
Dragoon?
Alright, so...
The OG Dragoon...
And then...
Dragoon...
Even better!
Alright.
I can knowledge as money!
Money!
You raised us from a baby!
Mother, what is this?
What do you mean?
Alright, nice.
That's all.
I'll use all my money on helmets.
Alright.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Hey Mario!
How many about Star Bits yet?
Us Lumas love them!
Oh, it's like ice now.
I just look up you.
Apparently he's in the Mario and Luigi RPG game.
And you have to play a majority of his screen time inside his belly.
It's so weird, very fast as you care.
So this is what you want representing you guys, Dragoon.
Is that what you want to represent you guys?
A little boar freak?
Is that what you want?
No, yes.
There are two Dragoons.
Never mind.
That's not us.
Is that what you wanted?
You guys wanted to be little freaks?
What you wanted to greet me.
Why can't you love us?
No key, Mother!
Why are you king shaming us, Mother?
Delsa, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You, Dragoon, I am what you made me.
Oh, fuck, I forgot.
I forgot fighting doesn't do anything.
Look, alright, I want to see what you... alright, let's send out dot dot dot Dragoon.
I want to see what it looks like in the back.
I need to know.
Oh my god.
Only the head shows up.
You're so big that only... only the head shows up right now.
Oh, it doesn't affect... he's too big.
He's too fucking big.
What?
Nothing works?
Okay, apparently you can only let...
Oh my god, what are you?
Oh my god, you can't even...
Oh my god, you can't even escape!
I can't even... I can't set any...
Why?
You actually just...
Oh nice, I have the Dragontail.
Okay, thank god.
Oh, thank god.
I have Dragontail.
I have one more move.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Nice.
Okay, it's normal, ghost.
Okay, we're back.
We're back.
Jesus Christ, STOP!
Okay, it's over.
Oh, thank god.
My child.
My real child.
My...
Leveled up.
My real child leveled up.
Thank god.
Oh, it's Penguin!
What the fuck?
Why do you look like that?
Why do you look at me like that with those eyes?
Why does he look...
Whoa!
Like, hey.
I heard there's a spot open right now.
Alright, let's be Penguin.
Oh, yeah.
Why is she looking at us like that?
She knows what you did.
Yo!
Why is it like...
Why is it looking at me like that?
Exactly!
Noot, noot.
Oh, my.
Alright.
She knows what I did.
Oh, yeah.
I said I would give Demon one.
Okay, Demon.
Demon.
Demon...
Goon.
Alright, there you go.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
I wanna go back here.
There's something up here that I saw.
Yeah, there was an item.
Fuck.
I keep walking into the tree for some reason.
Yeah, that's a demon, alright.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, it's an aluma.
Oh,
it's an aluma.
Get out of here, dad.
Okay.
Oh, is this ice?
It is.
Okay, I gotta figure this out.
Okay, no.
I have to hit that area.
Okay, that's easy.
Never melt ice.
Yes.
Ew.
You're looking for a silver star?
Well, I have one.
I'll give it to you.
You can overcome my trial.
Alright, that's fine.
I'm dead.
You can melt anything.
Oh, shit.
He's empowered.
Oh, my God.
Look how strong he feels.
There's nothing.
I have fire on my side.
That's right.
Yeah.
Wasted me...
Wasted 10 seconds of my life watching all the stats.
Oh, wait.
That's it?
You only have one.
Wow.
Great job.
Here you go, as promised.
Okay, he did not try that hard.
He literally only had...
Yeah.
I waited 10 seconds for that stupid power-up shit.
Check out my super grounded team!
Okay, poison pee.
Okay, I don't think I can sit on that.
Wait, no, I can.
Wait, I should...
No.
We'll use Flare Blitz.
Actually.
I'll like let Dad's butt rest a little bit.
He deserves it.
Oh, shit.
Oh, he had the recoil.
I forgot.
I forgot it hurts him a little.
Let it rest a little bit.
He's been doing a lot of work.
Oh, shit.
Okay, there's...
You know what?
It's time to get a little freaky though.
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
Don't...
Don't do that.
Never mind.
It wasn't worth it.
Forgot to have that move.
First impression?
What's that?
Only works...
Hits hard.
And first.
Only works first turn.
Is it worth it?
Does it not work in any other turn?
Wait, it's good?
Okay, I'll get rid of Skitter Smack then.
Yeah, you was not a good first impression.
First move every time it comes out.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
The only question is like, when does he ever get to come out?
Yay!
My beautiful child.
You leveled up.
My real son.
Man.
Good for him.
It's a snowy wonderland!
I'm freezing my calves off!
Oh, that's like a leveled up son.
Mother.
My first and only son.
We can't hear you.
Yes, you guys!
I only have one.
You're looking for a silver shark?
Well, I have one.
I'll give it to you.
You can overcome my trial.
Oh my god.
He knows what I said.
I know what you did last summer.
Oh my god.
It's another like five seconds of watching this.
Oh shit.
I was gonna be like, why do that when I can do this?
But he moved first.
What money?
Get down!
Get down from here.
Oh shit.
Wait.
He had focus sash.
Oh my god.
He believed in himself.
He went to sleep?
Wake up!
Are you fucking...
Oh my god.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I didn't realize it gave like, his full HP.
Oh, it didn't matter.
That's fucking right.
Get out of here.
Wow, great job.
Here you go, as promised.
Nice, I got a silver star.
Yay.
I wonder if there's any more mods I haven't caught yet.
Oh, it's a baby!
It's time to kidnap another child.
Nice.
Another child in my collection.
That I will adopt.
Sorry.
It's time to adopt another child, everybody!
Yay!
Oh my god.
See?
He wanted to be adopted, chat.
He wanted to be adopted.
Just a silly little guy.
He will say if you throw it off a cliff enough times, they may learn to fly.
People are dumb because penguins can't fly.
Yeah!
Alright, who wants to be a baby penguin?
I'm just giving them a new home.
Honestly, whoever used to take care of this child was a bad parent.
They let this child randomly talk to a stranger.
I wanna be a babe.
Alright.
Let's see.
Wait.
Does Broku have a...
Alright.
Broku have a...
Have one yet?
Bro...
Oh wait.
Actually...
Brogoon.
Yep.
Wait.
Broku already had one?
Alright.
That's it.
Rename time.
You thought you could trick me.
Oh yeah, he shared one with the guy we banished.
I forgot.
Alright.
Where is he?
No, he didn't.
Oh wait, no.
He's fine.
Oh no.
Oh, they were spreading misinformation?
Oh.
Damn.
Bro...
Broku remember their names.
Remember their names.
Several goons.
Okay, no.
He's fine.
He doesn't have...
He doesn't have one.
Yeah, I'm double checking.
Alright.
Man has enemies.
Wait.
Is he?
Oh, you lied!
Wait.
Okay.
Where are you?
You lied to all of us.
Wait.
In the...
The ugly thing?
Which one?
No, that's broken.
No, that's different.
That's different, guys.
That's...
That's broken bun.
This is different.
Okay.
Brogoon is different.
That's broku.
Wait.
Oh, remember your enemies.
It's okay.
You guys can't read just like me.
Now you know you're a actual...
You're a real dragoon.
Oh my god!
Look at those cheeks!
He went through a lot of...
He definitely got a lot of fillers.
Oh, that's critical!
Look at those...
Those...
He's been...
Sucking up...
A lot of air.
That's for sure.
And only air, guys.
Um...
Blustery cloud with winds strong enough to move toads.
Be careful when traveling on the clouds.
Stepping on can be a one-way trick back...
Back to the surface.
Alright.
Who wants to be Typhu?
This guy has a lot of experience.
He has a lot of experience, guys.
Not me?
Message retracted!
He said...
Not me?
And then you...
Removed your message?
And...
Okay.
Clamacoon.
Alright.
There we go.
You knew what you were getting into.
Oh, another one.
Man.
Oh, they heard about my club.
Alright.
One more star.
Alright, camper.
Mega mole.
Get out of here.
Oh, he looks so cool though.
He has...
Oh, he has little sunglasses on!
He's so cool.
Alright.
Sit on it.
Yay!
Oh, another laticle?
It's okay.
We can still...
Nothing is...
Nothing is unsinnable.
Wait.
Was it actually unsinnable?
Wait a minute.
No!
Okay, nice, nice.
Oh, he flinched.
Oh, okay.
I was gonna be like...
Wait.
Was it actually unsinnable?
What happened?
Okay, we actually gotta swap.
Alright.
Oh, you're setting up.
Don't worry.
I'll make you big and strong soon, Dragoon.
I'll make you be my strongest child.
What is...
How about Miromash?
Does Miromash do you well with this?
Oh, never mind.
What about Magnet?
What?
Oh, if that wasn't one HP.
Alright, Magnet Bomb.
I don't know the types for this.
Oh fuck.
Okay, I'm using...
I'm literally using every...
I'm using every move that's bad.
That's okay.
Okay.
Air slash.
Eventually, something will work.
Oh, okay.
Oh, that's awkward.
That's... Oh, that's awkward.
Whoops.
Oh, my God.
That would have been perfect.
That would have been perfect for this, but I can't.
He's literally won.
I can't risk it, guys.
We'll just brute force it.
No!
Crazy!
What the...
Sleep!
I'm fucking cursed.
It's okay.
Because he went to sleep.
That means I can swap.
All right, Dad.
This is it.
He's asleep.
This is your chance.
No!
No way!
He played me!
Oh, my God!
He played me like a fool!
It's all right.
Oh.
All right.
Never mind.
It's not okay.
Oh, shit.
It's red, Yoshi.
All right.
Don't worry.
The battle of the Yoshis.
I can't believe he played me like a fucking fool.
Yoshi!
All right.
What else is there?
His club again.
It's his club again.
Oh, my God.
I don't know who to...
Okay.
Stick bug.
Surely, stick bug will do okay against steel, right?
I don't know.
I don't... First impression.
Oh.
That's awkward.
Drain punch.
You're right.
That's okay.
We got... We got a fighting move.
Oh.
Thank God.
Okay.
Nice.
Things are okay.
Here goes my fire.
All right.
Things are okay, guys.
Nothing to worry about.
And we got a star piece, too.
All right.
Let's see.
I believe.
You know what?
Stick bug.
This is your time.
This is your time, stick bug.
Right here.
Right now.
You're looking for a silver star?
Well, I have one.
I'll give it to you who can overcome my trial.
I should warn you, though.
This trial is unlike the other ones you face.
Also, you'll be allowed to try and catch this one.
Are you properly prepared?
That's right.
I have stick bug.
Okay.
There's no way stick bug can kill him.
The first impression.
There's no way.
Oh, my God.
There's so many.
Oh, there's so...
Okay.
There you go.
You'll live.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
That's good.
That's good, guys.
He lived.
Guys.
Okay.
He didn't live.
That's awkward.
Oh, that's a little awkward.
That's a little awkward.
It's okay.
I can catch him now, right?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
He's a little strong.
Oh, and then he's gonna heal himself.
Oh.
Wow.
Stick bug.
It's like dying.
Dying did not mean much.
Oh.
Whoa.
That's awkward.
Oh, and then he hexes me.
Okay, cool.
Okay.
I can do two more hits.
All right.
He's full HP again.
Okay.
That's fine.
Surely I can do a meteor map.
Okay, I can't.
He's dead.
Oh.
Ooh.
Ah.
Okay.
That's fine.
Just tank it.
Don't kill it.
Oh, it's okay.
You'll just die.
Okay.
Never mind.
Never.
Oh, that's awkward.
Oh.
It's okay.
You're not gonna live.
But like...
You'll just...
Just be here to like...
No.
Oh, no.
My mother.
Ah!
My son!
I knew you could do it!
My
real...
Ah!
I knew it!
An ice mage with a heart as cold as his demeanor.
It is quick to show off its chilly powers by freezing enemies immediately.
I knew you could do it, my real son.
Alright.
Alright, who wants to be the Crystal K?
What do you mean?
He got us!
He got us Crystal K!
He did it!
Alright, let's see.
Hmm...
Yeah!
I have a favorite child, because I only have one child!
Alright, let's get...
Let's see...
Uh...
We'll do...
Yeah, we'll do...
Skar...
Let's see...
K...
R...
Skar...
Wait, do I have...
Three...
G...
Okay, whoops.
O...
N...
There you go!
Alright!
Yay!
Here you go!
As promised!
Yay!
I did it, guys!
Mario!
Okay, we only have two...
Two left!
Surely there's nobody up here, right?
Oh, nice!
Well, I didn't really happy with these!
Alright, let's go back.
Let's go back and heal.
We are a little...
We're a little...
We are a little low right now.
Yay!
We did it!
Mario!
I sense you have all five silver stars!
Don't feel jealous, but Luigi was able to tame them before you were!
If you defeat me slowly, you may be able to reach him in the Molten Kingdom!
Are you ready to challenge me?
Yes, I am, Rosalina!
Yes, I am!
Then I hope you're properly prepared!
Whoa!
You stand on the precipice of greatness!
I ask you to take it in!
But I also understand that the haste is of importance to your quest!
Let's begin!
We don't need a save, guys!
We're invincible!
Oh my god, Senza...
Oh, I forgot Rice is here!
Wait...
Wait, Rice, why are you here?
Oh, I swapped you out!
Whoops!
I was like, why are you here?
Oh, shit!
Oh, fuck!
Okay, that's fine!
That's fine!
I just gave her...
I just gave her a freebie, you know?
Just a little freebie!
Jesus Christ!
What?!
With 1 HP?!
Oh, no!
I forgot!
Rosalina is a psychic...
Is a psychic user!
Does that mean I will have my pressure, Mario?
Oh, this is awkward!
What is Luba?
Oh, fuck!
That's Luba!
There's Luba!
There goes Luba!
Goodbye, Luba!
How the fuck did that Luba live over Luba?!
Bye, Luba!
Oh, sky attack!
Wait, that might be a good move!
Oh, search us out?
No, if it takes you two moves...
Fuck that!
Wait, actually...
Wait, is it two moves?
I can't tell...
Oh, yeah, yeah.
If it takes two moves...
Nah!
Alright.
He's a Luba, not a fighter.
Alright, sit.
Yay!
What?!
How are they living with 1 HP?!
There's no way you're bigger than Dad!
There's no way!
Oh, he has heavy defense?
Oh, okay.
I was gonna say, like, what the fuck?
How is he bigger?
Oh, shit.
He's faster, too.
I forgot.
He has...
He has legs!
I risked it.
It's fine.
Okay.
It's okay.
Wait, what's strong against psychic?
Bug, right?
Bug!
Sick bug!
It's time, sick bug!
It's your moment to shine!
Here we go.
Mr. Eye?
What's a Mr. Eye?
Oh, my God!
It's an eye!
Stars, sky...
Oh, that's a Mr. Eye!
I was like, the fuck is that?
Oh...
I pricked it.
I pricked your eye.
Yoink!
Got your eye!
What enemy is that from?
Egg bomb!
My son!
Egg bomb.
Just like old times, son.
Just like old times.
Yeah!
Mario, you're a formidable battler.
And a wonderful person.
Please, take this power star.
Yay!
We got the comm observatory power star!
Yippee!
We did it!
And here, take this team.
It contains the moose cycle cut.
Yay!
Your seventh power star.
The last one you're left to collect is in the Molten Kingdom.
Your brother defeated me earlier and must be there now.
For you to catch up and beat him, you need to be quick.
I've prepared a method of sending you right to the entrance of Bowser's castle.
Wait, he has...
Oh no, Bowser Jr. has the last power star.
Simply, talk to my Luna and he'll send you on your way.
It isn't...
This isn't your only way there.
The warp zone will also have a warp pipe prepared for you.
So I only offer an expedited route.
My Luna still offers healing and supplies for your party.
So feel free to come back whenever you're ready.
Oh, well, it takes a while?
Alright, let's just heal.
Alright.
Where is the launch pipe?
Take me to the area.
I demand to be launched.
Alright, I'll save now.
What's this?
Oh!
Alright, this one.
There's Bowser's castle.
That's far enough, pal.
Oh shit.
That's quite far enough, Mario.
Seems my friends have been in contact with you.
You owe me.
Well, it's become quite apparent that you're not in the market for paying back your debts.
Given you wanted to, the interest you've accumulated is much too great for you.
So I'm afraid it's time for you to sleep with the Bargs.
Boys?
No, no, no.
Not the...
Nothing personal, pal.
No!
Not the Bargs!
That's alright.
Dad!
You got this!
I forgot to swap.
I for...
Alright.
This is a little awkward.
Um...
Oh wait, I can do this.
String sap.
This is still a little awkward, but...
I forgot to swap, you guys.
That's fine.
You should die, right?
Wait, why are you so slow, Rice?
You have the last move?
Wait, that's a stat?
Oh...
Goodbye.
I
saw grass, okay, guys?
I saw grass and I thought...
This is it.
He won't disappoint me.
It's literally lava.
Oh no, stick bug.
No!
Yay!
Oh look, you leveled up, Bryce.
At least you leveled up.
Okay.
It's fine.
I have storm throw.
It still works.
I'll keep punching fire.
I can punch fire!
Yeah!
Punch the fire!
Oh, you both wanted...
That's funny.
They both wanted to do...
Um...
The new sunny day.
Yay!
Free move for me!
That's okay.
Oh, it's just a little damage.
You're fine.
Punch the fire!
Punch it!
Yay!
Okay, that's not a lot of damage.
But that's okay.
It'll be fine.
I'm also fire.
I should be fine too.
Oh, that's a lot of damage.
What the fuck?
How was that so much damage?
I'm also fire!
What?
Okay.
Uh...
I'll just try Sucker Punch.
Fuck it.
Yeah, that's crazy.
That fire move is fucking insane.
Yeah, but I'm level 59.
That is so fucking buff.
That's right.
Cam.
Fucking.
Send me to the blogs.
Plus!
I'd leave your jobs for the failures.
We're sorry!
Imbecile!
Now, now.
Let's not be hasty, eh?
Why aren't you?
Cause they're all your debts forgiven!
Bye now!
Yay!
Look guys, see?
I beat the loan sharks!
See?
Party money's not bad!
Guys, look at that!
Buy all the money you want!
Luigi, don't worry about going through the whole castle.
Just follow us into the throne room.
We'll give you the power star.
And some need it alone time with Bowser.
Oh, that's okay, bro.
I should work for it like everyone else.
Awesome.
It's not really fun when I'm being dragged, right?
No, we insist.
We want you to get to the wish before Mario like everyone else does.
It doesn't matter to me if I get my wish.
I'm just playing to have fun with my bro.
Bro?
But Papa got mushroom pizza delivered for all of us.
Mushroom pizza, you say?
Of course, it's all waiting in the throne room.
Um...
Can we actually get mushroom pizza?
Let me pull out the royal credit card.
It's a business expense, guys.
Zechra, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I just found out X-Naut has the scrappy ability.
I can throw hands with Mint.
Mario, wait up!
It looks like Luigi has been locked inside the throne room with Bowser.
Bowser Jr. and Kamek.
It's a sturdy door with a sturdy lock on it.
So you need to make your way through the whole castle and find that Bowser key.
All right, nice.
All right.
What's that?
Why am I here?
Of course, I want to give you something to help you get through the castle.
Oh, I got the gad pill.
What's that?
That right there is my brand new gad pill.
To scare away any Bowser pesky captures from attacking you while you're walking around.
Oh, and don't worry about how it works.
The smell is showing me too noticeable to the wear.
Now then, I'm heading back to my lab.
Okay, we can catch some stuff and then we'll use it.
All right.
That's a good time to stop, guys.
Oh, because I have a lot of stuff to do today.
Anyway, a lot of stuff.
But it's great to be back, everyone.
Oh, yeah.
Before we go, it's new emotes time.
Guys.
All right.
Let me...
Let me grab the emotes real quick.
We'll have to download it.
All right.
So for those who don't know, we have two new emotes that we are going to be...
We're going to be uploading today.
Let me sort this out.
So, two new emotes that we have is...
I'm trying to grab it right now.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
So here are two new emotes.
We have this one.
I'm happy for you.
Because I know you guys love using that one.
And we have the side eye.
So these are two new emotes that we're uploading.
And we are going to be getting rid of...
From popular vote.
From your fellow dragoons.
These are the two emotes that we will be getting rid of.
So say goodbye to them.
Say goodbye.
They have lived a good life.
But they shall be replaced.
Don't worry.
They will...
They'll still have...
They'll still be alive on Twitch.
So...
I have to do that too.
I need to remember to...
I need to remember to like...
To like upload the Twitch emotes as well.
But...
Uh...
Oh, what's the word?
What's the word?
To update it.
Yeah, to update my Twitch emotes.
Because that's something I gotta do.
But anyway.
Alright.
Where are these two?
Let me get rid of them.
Alright.
Happy...
Or...
So happy.
Alright.
Say goodbye!
Say goodbye to these emotes!
And then...
Where's the other one?
My emotes.
But wait.
Thank you to the super chat.
Thank you.
And then this one will be...
Okay.
I'm gonna rename this...
To Tomato.
And then this one will be...
SideEye.
Alright.
Are you guys ready?
Wait.
Give me a sec.
I'm not ready.
Sorry.
I wasn't ready.
Alright.
In three...
Two...
One.
And they shall be gone.
Oh.
They're gone now.
They're gone.
They're now just squares.
They're gone forever.
Never.
They...
But now you get...
Now you get so happy.
Happy for you.
And sideEye.
You're in two new emotes.
We have voted two emotes off the island.
Well...
Now you can welcome your new...
Your new siblings.
Your new friends.
Where's the sideEye?
Oh.
You just gotta refresh.
Anyway.
You guys gotta refresh the chat.
And you should see it.
Hey guys.
I'm gonna call it here.
Thank you everybody for watching.
I have a very busy day today.
Since I have a lot of work obligations from...
Uh...
That were super backed up.
So I gotta work on that.
But a great time stream for you guys.
As always.
Uh...
Dad's gonna be back in like...
Maybe like 20 or 30 minutes.
So I gotta like...
Take care of dad too.
When he gets here.
Hey guys.
I hope you guys have a fun time.
Another Super Mario mod.
Does anyone know how many more parts I have left?
For Super Mario mod?
Maybe I can finish it in two more streams guys.
Do you think that's possible?
Cause I might try to finish it next week.
I'll do two parts next week.
Anyway guys.
As always everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up.
And move around.
To get that blood flowing.
And if you.
Except for me.
Head to bed.
Cause...
You deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.